et pour ça on a benn et alan nous
habituelles note witcher salut les gars
comment ça va
j'ai jamais fait oui c'est vrai mais il
est sur la lys et quand tu veux tu es
chez toi c'est
pour parler des prospects de la g-league
on a invité petit franck rogner 2 du ccs
et de celtic france c'est justement ça
va ça va ça va saluer bien merci pour
l'invitation un plaisir et pierre de nba
league france qu'on aura malheureusement
pas l'occasion mémoire klépierre jours à
tous bonsoir à tous oui malheureusement
pas de caméras mais magnifique ce match
et qui je pense ça va on va égayer cette
conversation d'un peu plus de deux
heures exactement comme tu l'as dit
relais parti pour deux heures n'hésitez
pas bien sûr a commenté vous avez un
chat à disposition avec des règles de
bienséance habituel on va partir tout de
suite sur le premier thème donc
pierre ce sera surtout avec toi là la
jelly pour ceux qui savent pas qui
débarque un peu l'âge et des ailes à la
thymine d'agde il y arriver c'est quoi
la g-league donc à vince été nommé
d-league donc c'est une ligue de
développement parce que c'était pour
n'diaye dit
donc aussi d un peu comme la petite
soeur d'un billet on a trop tendance à
oublier que scénique professionnels
aussi bon malheureusement
lld peine cette image de petite soeur de
l'envié qui lui colle un peu trop à la
peau à mon goût parce qu'il ya des vrais
talents mais ça sert pas quand vous
voyez des jeunes qui n'ont pas le niveau
cap au niveau une bille et là bas
donc ligue de développement
recoupements 28 équipes seuls
28 équipes affiliées du moins tant
qu'affilié une franchise nba bien que
bourdin des phénix qui n'ont pas
d'équipé
deux équipes non affiliés donc les
victimes de laquelle on va parler ce
soir et les mexico city capitale est si
on a une équipe d'expansion basé à
mexico mexico city quasiment qu'avec des
joueurs locaux donc de mexico city qui
était à 20 dans la ligue professionnelle
américaine
mais qui a été intronisé cette année
après la goebbels angeli
dignity donc c'est l'équipe de
développement de la g-league donc qui
est un associé directement avec la vie
que c'est pas une équipe à part entière
avec un président
jean etc c'est la ligue qui gère ça donc
qu elle y accueille les joueurs qui
n'ont pas forcément envie d'être de
faire le chemin classique c'est-à-dire
risques aux lanciers et n'diaye
ça a été aussi la première
la première équipe non universitaires on
va dire au niveau après universitaire à
payer ses joueurs cinquante partis pour
ça que j'ai une grille nedjma twingo et
des chaînes x même s'il est resté angeli
glee cette année
ont signé là bas au début et
malheureusement ou heureusement pour
certains
les équipiers ont été obligés de de
s'aligner sur sur ce genre de truc parce
qu'ils ont senti que leur compétitivité
allait en prendre un coup
qu'est ce que je pourrais dire d'autre
je pense que j'ai un peu tout dit
c'est donc la digue qui vit quand même
aussi un peu comme c'est à peu près les
mêmes thèmes line que l'envié de fait
que aussi il ya beaucoup de les fameux
tous et qui sont majoritairement
angeli pour la plupart et tant qu'ils
sont rappelés par les équipes nba donc
c'est un petit peu le même programme
voix en fait les les équipes nba un peu
comme une équipe une et une équipe de si
vous voulez notre magnifique championnat
français
mais qu ils hésitent de geely et les
équipes de nba ont le même
temps les membres du coaching staff
funky ses charges c'est à dire que il ya
un mcdonald par exemple c'est parce que
c'est l'exemple le plus connu uni
conitnuer aux raptors ont fait tous deux
des deux ou trois pigeons gillig nickner
ça a été élu coach de l'année en
d-league matt elliott a fait six ans sur
le banc du hockey cibles où l'équipe a
filé de quessy donc on a vraiment un
staff qui changent constamment et avec
tout le monde qui qui monte qui monte et
qui descend et les équipes et les coachs
sont toutes en relation pour avoir
exactement le même plein de jeux comme
ça si jamais un tout et contracte et les
amener à les gens du billet ou si
quelqu'un d'autre de l'équipe du
physique parce que n'importe qui peut
d'une équipe de lille peut tromper une
seconde
le calendrier avait il y avait un
calendrier réagi à la halle aux débuts
de la
j-league choqué
et pour la manière dont vous loupé je
suis désolé forcément il faut que mon
livre il faut comme interrompant que
j'ai précisément spécifié qu'il fallait
pas me faire chier pendant deux ans
maintenant et nos deux si jamais il y
avait des calendriers un petit peu ce
que ceux spécifiques ou des pc qui peut
pas en même temps en championnat
alors il ya eu là cette saison un peu
particulière comme la saison d'avant et
dans la gueule donc on a eu une
pré-saison d'une vingtaine de matchs
pour voir un peu comme jouer les joueurs
etc on a eu le winter showcase donc
pendant trois jours après après ce petit
moment et demi deux mois de pré saison
donc avec 5000 un chèque de 5000 euros à
la clé pour les joueurs et pour le staff
qui a été remporté par les des lavoirs
blue coat
du mv blida
équipe à fait thierry fis et là du coup
depuis après toutes les équipes ne
jouent pas le même nombre de matchs en
même temps c'est à dire que là il ya si
vous avez regardé le classement
d'algérie il ya un certain certaines
équipes qui ont joué neuf matches comme
les raptors par exemple qui sont
premiers de la conférence s il semble je
n'ai pas regardé depuis 11 jours donc ça
je suis passé à bouger mais les raptors
normands sont bien calés en mieux placé
tandis que les spurs manuel de l'équipe
que je suis plus vieux que je suis fan
des spurs de san antonio de base
a joué que cinq matches donc forcément
il ya une petite inégalités au niveau
des matchs pour l'instant mais ça
devrait se rééquilibre au niveau du dieu
du all star break ou là tout le monde
aura joué à peu près bien du même nom de
ma chance
ok est ce qu'il ya des gens contre
ajoutée ou sinon on va commencer à
spécifiquement regarder timide night
elles dépendent wali scolaire s'est
il lève le doigt au fond de la mine
c'est comme la preuve de la nba avait
pas de ligue mineure comme toutes les
dents les coudes les deux les autres
secours aux pas américain teal baseball
au hockey il ya des ligues mineures ont
lieu où il ya un lien que contre des
équipes qui peuvent envoyer donc faire
des échanges de joueurs allaient tester
des joueurs les ramener la nba pas trop
ce truc là donc c'était et avait été 12
15 joueurs et ensuite c'était compliqué
de tête retrouver du temps de jeu
trouver les moyens de faire progresser
certains types de joueurs et donc ce
modèle là permet en fait
aux équipes et le biais de je trouve
d'affaires que de faire comme de ça se
passe dans un autre que dans d'autres
micro semaine d'avoir un système de
ligues mineures c'est très sain pour les
jeunes europe pour les jeunes arabes qui
veulent
une idée du concept c'est un peu comme
avoir une équipe de réserve
savoir une équipe de réserve pour être
capable justement d'aller chercher de
développer des joueurs d'aller
rechercher lorsque ya les blessures où
il ya des bébés c'est des performances
insatisfaisantes
si nous mêmes des pandémies là on l'a vu
très récemment avec le nouveau alors
qu'ils ont été rappelés avec les cas qu
vidé beaucoup venaient de chile
règle réserve a fonctionné aussi à
il ya des joies qui ont des prix et les
joies cordée pris leur retraite musicale
the world wind corp était avec l'ap en
2002 madame salue ton salut jura
le jura qui est en train de mettre qui a
25 points de moyenne en trois matchs
alors qu'un train de se refaire une
belle santé à part avoir été dans le
coaching staff des rockets cela j'aime
ce qui est tout énervé il envie de
rejouer j'ai motion
maintenant on va se donc comme je le
disais on va faire un focus sur la
thymine dijk ça vient d'où ça sort
depuis quand tout ça tout ça fait un
petit topo pour ceux qui n'ont pas du
tout suivi parce que ça va être quand
même ça s'annonce comme étant quelque
chose de assez durable et fiable
donc je suppose que du coup c'est moi
qui vais le plus facile pour toi
moi les victimes du coup elle a été
instaurée on va dire la saison dernière
avec les signatures de notamment jamie
green et je m'étonne kong à des chaînes
x également
[Musique]
voilà c'était les quatre prospects entre
guillemets principaux
auxquels sont tout aussi voire jamais
joué samedi
on a tendance à l'oublier car ils sont
tous c'est un peu le fan zeng de cette
année
de cette année là de deux ligues night
mewa du coup une équipe est jeune donc
des développements qui a joué les 15
matches de la saison régulière donc de
la gueule parce qu'une quinzaine de
matchs
ouais une équipe basée à walnut creek en
floride en californie pardon en ville ou
en afrique en californie avec brian shaw
com
comme entraîneur
le but de l'équipe ça a toujours été de
former ces jeunes dans un cadre
professionnel de leur apprendre à être
des meilleurs pros et à être d
être formés en fait pour être à une
bière et d'idées l'ordre
et ouais c'est vraiment l'équipe suprême
de développement qui a qui avait pour
but peut-être pas 1er mai de concurrence
et
de concurrencer le système entier et
et webo là c'est l'équipe entre
guillemets rêvé pour un jeune pour le
jeune prospect qui voudraient se
développer parce qu'il a des des jeux et
des anciens joueurs nba a autour de lui
il a un coaching staff dans le sien
le staff nba il a des infrastructures de
niveau nba et joue dans la petite soeur
de la nba franchement
c'est c'est je pense le truc rêvé pour
un jeune échoué
avant que lundi et prennent ces mesures
là ils étaient les seuls jeunes daleux
de la rage à être payés pour jouer au
basket
après c'est pas des contrats faramineux
non plus mais je m'en rappelle plus
exactement des fourchettes il me semble
que ils étaient payés charles grad 207
en ligne 300 millions comme savané
depuis
c'est peut-être pour les peu pour les
plus bas mais il me semble que j'avais
vu 2 1 200 et quelques pour les
de ça quelques pour les pour combiner
les greens d'un dernier donc
voilà donc c'était la bonne occasion
pour eux est la preuve james gray un
train de péter commis gabon
malheureusement un peu moins mais janine
greiner est en train de se réveiller en
nba ça fait plaisir de voir l'évolution
de ces jeunes là et je pense que ce
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
contrairement là la n 6 et le l'objectif
premier n'était pas le but d'aider match
on imagine déjà n'y pouvait faire des
erreurs et pouvait vraiment être les
stars est focus sur la wan si l objectif
principal des coachs a par contre tu
vois mon fils c'est de gagner des
matches et donc du coup les jeunes au
moins de responsabilités sont plus mis
de côté c'est donc que tu vois
et la kasbah après aussi tu vas pas
remonter ta chaise on dirait que tu
parles de ta chaise
moi ouais parce que déjà les bras si
rêver en fait si tu veux j'ai une
famille de mes déchets et donc j'en ai
très bien sûr mois au fur et à mesure et
je suis obligé de les contenter tu vois
qu'un brouillon et ligne présente son
meilleur profil
lâché chose en fait
bon bah c'était le point animaux là on
est content
ça joue là inactive pour ce qui est du
monde a vu des matchs c'est quoi un peu
ce qu'on devine de la philosophie de
design art le coach
sa veuve alice bras je pense que ça
s'est parlé commencez-vous simuler la
joue très cynique la haine l'année
dernière c'était horrible ces quatre
sociétés
enfin je n'étais pas là pour rouge était
là pour voir green porter la balle chi
ming un peu et je me voyais et avait que
17 fait pour jarrett jack et où je
trouve ça insupportable
c'est pas le rôle de c'est parce qu'on
voulait cette année je trouve que c'est
beaucoup mieux les prospects joue
beaucoup plus d aller on avait beaucoup
de jouets deux par deux trous et
beaucoup et green cunningham après todd
joue avec knicks mais on voyait pas
souvent les gens ensemble cette année de
plus en plus en effet de l'émergence en
mai juin à 3,4 sur le terrain en même
temps il ya c'est plus moderne faria et
que son pick and roll ça court ça joue
en transition donc moi je suis très
satisfait de la manière dont il épongera
cette année franchement je trouve que
c'est
je suis à dire c'est plus proche de ce
qu'on trouvera une billets que 95% des
des programmes initiés en terme de deux
manières de jouer donc c'est intéressant
ouais je pense aussi ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut dire si le niveau de
l'opposition
c'est quelque chose d'affaires qu'on se
demande souvent quand on essaye
d'évaluer les transmet et beaucoup se
demandent mais oui mais la g-league
qu'est ce que ça vaut en terme
d'opposition et en fait je pense que
c'est important de préciser quand même
si elle est jouée raisons plus ou moins
le même âge
deux ou trois ans près et plus ou moins
le même parcours où la même expérience à
part quelques cas exceptionnels alors
qu'angie l'ictu va affronter des joueurs
beaucoup plus âgés qui ont déjà
l'expérience nba pour certains c'est pas
rare de voir des joueurs expérimentés
faire quelques matches angélique pour se
remettre d'une blessure ou même parce
qu'ils sont un peu sorti de la rotation
par leur coach boumedienne et donc
automatiquement l'adversité être même
plus proche de la nba que ce qu'on peut
avoir en russie et sur la barre des
matches donc je pense que ça l'adversité
et le style de jeu c'est important parce
que c'est quand même plus proche de ce
qu'on trouvera nguyen que ce que tu as
initié par des programmes j'avais fait
le compte n'est dernière pour une des
équipes joué par contre knight et les
douze joueurs qu'ils soient quitter
l'équipe du jazz l'es12 alors il y avait
2-3 lottery pick il y avait et 12
avaient été des eaux le conférence des
joueurs de le meilleur d'or cinq
conférences durant leur parcours initié
c'était qui donc c'était le niveau de
jeu est plus élevée fournir souvent on
aime bien taper sur l'algérie est
peut-être un peu je trouve surévalué l'a
initié dans la qualité de jeu et tout ça
en réalité quand à 12 joueurs qui sont
ensemble qui ont plus de 23 ans qui ont
étions peut-être jouer en europe joue en
nba et qui ont été parmi les dents les
équipes types de leur conférence ça
c'est très intéressant de voir des mecs
de 18 19 ans temps je vous raconte ça
il ya un truc qui toujours se trouve
assez intéressant pour la timide net
c'est le côté en cadeau on reconnaît par
des jeunes par est pas d des anciens
autres il ya toujours il y avait des
amis en une seule année dernière le
putsch eater je laissais démérité
way qui ont encore la voilà enfin si les
faits dont parle la regarde et à dia il
y avait mon tableau l'an dernier qu'il
ya monaco maintenant qu'un
vrai joueur d'euroligue
donc ça c'est toujours intéressant pour
eux aussi au niveau explique au monde y
tient j'aime bien cette question je vous
laisse ou m messieurs oui oui ça se
passe comment pour l'ivoire de l'insight
il y en aurait en fait ouais non
vraiment il ya un vrai
regard des
conneries rires des insultes il ya un
vrai suivi universitaire qui est fait
alors je suis plus du tout à
l'université j'avais lu au début mais
alors j'ai plutôt qu'aller à quelle
université mais en fait ça compte dans
leur paye à leur pays il ya donc il ya
lorsque leur chèque de base qui sont
censés percevoir et en fait d'un ça il
ya leurs bourses d'études en fait ils
ont eu à
l'université qu'il aurait payé parce
qu'en fait c'est le un des premiers
problèmes c'est ce que disait chérif
abdoul rahim en interview il a fait une
interview sur le site de la télé que
comme sur l'insight et on lui pose cette
question donc est-ce que à peu près la
même la même question donc est-ce que
niveau universitaire ça se passe quand
on est justement en fait ils y ont eu un
bris cursus universitaire avec des
la possibilité du moins si le vol de
poursuivre leur leur cursus ou donc
commencer
après évidemment s'ils vont en billets
bon ils arrêtent leur cursus de leur
cursus mais le but n'était pas de ne pas
leur offrir une éducation en tête et
pourrait le faire après la leur carrière
j'ai vu qu'ils sont moins participé à la
bo fonctionnement entre guillemets de
guinée team tout pour le quasiment tous
pleuré payante est le but c'est adeline
team c'est que de les accompagner de
leurs 17 18 19 ans a jusqu'à la fin de
leur quart elle même après
tout un programme à est
encore en place d'ailleurs est encore
mis en place pour
tout un programme encore mis en place
pour pour les chiffres après leur
carrière et même pendant leur carrière
donc c'est c'est vraiment de méfaits du
coup tu veux dire que michael foster
jugnot et d'apprendre à lire après
[Musique]
vous avez un agenda je sais pas
et qui vous fait la passe d
eau à ce qu'on attend et ce peut être
qu'on attend un petit peu moins pour la
draft 2022 je vous propose qu'on
commence à parler de john hardy qu'est
ce que vous pensez de se voir là
récemment si vous faites abstraction de
son match cataclysmique
qui les lui y est on finit avec un
magnifique 0 sur 11 je crois quelque
chose comme ça
voilà ben ben je sais que tu l'aies oui
tu l'a beaucoup raté des tirs
oui parce que des matches
quelques-uns d'entre le côté d'ailleurs
chacune d une maison un peu de thé brick
5 je crois que
je
un jour à quelle qualité qui
est un schalke
capable de créer son propre histoire
c'est pas des joueurs qui skie 4
d'habitude on n'a qu'à penser je ne
prends l'exemple de dépouiller de
lalinde qui était un agent est inquiète
m
2,3 y y pour le joueur qu'il est
aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il était un dock qui de droit qui
tenait des shoots a bear pour détourner
ronde
de beslan à deux points qui s'est
vraiment sans contrat pendant cosquer
ouais ouais ça laon puis sommes ici il
s'est trouvé ici trouver je comprends
pas les hommes mais je sais que
l'inefficacité de jaden a redit aux
shoots et un peu dégueulasse
présentement mais c'est gérable c'est un
problème qui est gérable puis ce soit le
genre de joie au calme va l'attendre de
parler dans le processus un pré draft
avant demain par une idée si jean draft
ou non ce qui est un peu moi g rap c'est
le mode d fort en défensive c'est là ce
n'est pas acheter sans défense presque
jamais ils se barrent la tête dans des
écrans à peu près tout le temps si c'est
difficile à voir c'est pas très agréable
je pense que j'ai vu je regarde et qu'on
ne sente bien ce matin il s'est fait et
en paix par tahar besbas ce qui prend un
joueur de très haut niveau dans le vif
en joie qui très solide sur ses pattes
non plus dans les écrans peut paraître
cinq ou six fois pendant le match donc
ça c'est très inquiétant ces points
créateurs n'ont pu pour les autres pour
créer un port naturel mais ça ça se
développe jusqu'à un certain point qu'à
moi l'important avec de leur dit c'est
qu'il va falloir une équipe qui lui
mettre la balle dans les mains c'est toi
qui m'as tu une équipe qu'il met la
balle dans les mains et qui trouve des
solutions pour travailler autour de lui
c'est un joueur que je déteste pas mais
que je suis pas convaincu que je me
trouvais d'autres le tir de l'avoir mis
dix neuvième dans mon big balls
je regardais en fait ça mais de moins en
moins sûr
je rejoins c'est ben notre constat ce
qui frappe c'est sa défense
effectivement où c'est un des pires
défenses ans que j'ai jamais vu mais
dans le sens où pas qu'il fait pas des
efforts ce qui se fait prendre tous les
écrans vraiment dans tous les écrans ben
il a dit ça c'est dramatique j'ai un peu
plus en amour que lui sur sa capacité à
créer pour les autres je trouve qu'il y
avait des vraies qualités de passes
maîtrise déjà trois niveaux de
passe-passe direct par ce seul passe
lobée capable de kick etc c'est un des
meilleurs dribbles dans le petit
périmètre de tout là de toute la cuvée
il est vraiment très très fort pour pour
sortir d'une situation difficile de
changer de direction de changer de
vitesse etc
- ce qui va me gêner le plus pour son
stock draft c'est pas forcément son
pourcentage de tirs pas forcément la
défense et ses capacités athlétiques je
trouve que j'attendais un athlète
supérieur des études ont comparé diane
greene c'est la moitié de ce que
j'allais me peut faire verticalement
quoi pourquoi m'ont vraiment pas beau ça
beaucoup de difficultés au contact et ça
ça me gêne un peu plus
ouais je puisse penser à cameron thomas
ce que j'aimais beaucoup mais son
gainage sans l'équilibré la puissance
qu'il avait au contact l'an dernier donc
gilles à peu près dans le même registre
que ben je pense valoir voir un peu plus
haut mais après dans ce style
moi honnêtement et
un peu c'est un peu différent j'ai pas
la même approche que sur janeiro dit que
d'autres parce que j'étais déjà pas très
haut sur lui et en fait moi j'avais
juste besoin du contexte gillig pour
voir si il était un de mes deux premiers
tiers c'est simple parce que de ce que
j'avais vu équipes luttent plus jeune
donc high school et tous voila c'était
un score incroyable mais on pouvait voir
déjà qu'en terme de déficiences de
qualités athlétiques pour moi ça allait
être compliqué d'en faire un porteur de
balle numéro 1 avec l'impressionnant
donc je me suis dit très bien il va
aller dans le jilin c'est un deuxième
contexte est ce que dans ce contexte là
ça doit être son année normalement voilà
en fait c'est le problème de dj dan
hardy c'est qu'il joue avec scott
anderson et donc malheureusement pas une
pâti de la comparaison parce que cette
année c'est l'équipe de dieu de nardi
c'est essentiel est le porteur de balle
c'est essentiel l'attaquant numéro 1 est
ce qu'il est d'ailleurs ce qu'il est
sauf que il ne fait pas de manière
extrêmement efficace donc pour moi ce ne
sera pas un joueur qui à qui je pense à
ça non je donnerai la balle en tant
qu'options numéro une en nba pour pour
pour gagner des matches mais je pense
quand même que il a dit qu'il n'était
pas fou qui progresse beaucoup de lancer
dans la création collective je trouve
que son tir même si la mécanique est pas
parce que tu es un bon tireur je pense
qu'il va il va tirer en biais donc ouais
je pense que ce sera un garde un garde
et n'oubliez solide
donc je suis je
rappelle un petit peu plus haut parce
que moi c'est quand même quelque chose
que je vois là il peut pour l'heure il
pleut il pleut il pleut il peut mettre
un match up make her comme on l'a dit
après voilà je pense que si on en
attendait énormément et en fait c'est ça
le problème le problème pour moi c'est
ça c'est quand on fait tout le monde
l'avait mis
trois top-5 de sa leçon de son big board
ils étaient mode dans les mangroves
partout mais ça fait pas trop avec ce
que je trouve on voyait l étage
inférieur mais les gens ils vont me dire
où il fait une mauvaise saison c'est
décevant parce que moi et on leur a dit
qu'ils étaient si fortes moi je trouve
qu'il ya déjà des petits des petits
soucis dans son jeu mais pour moi il
fait quand même il n'est pas au ray mais
franchement il fait ce qu'il a à faire
part avant et le tir ça va ça mais tu y
tourner après hugh répondre à lui de
joie
ouais bof je pense que tout a déjà été
dit je rejoins rejoint à l'année et
l'udc sur la capacité de création et
notamment pour les autres ou en fait je
trouve que c'est un meilleur créateur
pour les autres que ce que veut montrer
son style de jeu en est enfin moi je
vais beaucoup de flash à la passe sur
click'n'rock sur drive in teak qui sont
très intéressants
et après la de ça et je là dessus je
vends le jour à l'année et moi c'est ce
qui fait que je pense que j'ai un peu
plus haut que hugo ben c'est sa capacité
à se créer son tir notamment sur pull up
et je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
qui est très important dans la
projection d'un prospère nba surtout sur
ce profil tard et explorer
ouais je ne pense pas que ce soit une
option numéro un comme l'a dit allen
mais je pense que ce genre de scoreur
qui est qui cas ça dans le sang en fait
tu sens qu'il a qu'une envie à chaque
fois c'est l'essai de scorer alors ça a
les défauts ça amène les défauts qui
vont avec mais mais en plus a été flashé
à la passe je pense que ça reste assez
intéressante
tu gères quoiqu'elle ait connu
normalement assez souvent qu'est ce que
tu en penses à tour niveau de l'égout
geely je suis
assez d'accord avec tout ce qui se dit
que il a été beaucoup en fait pour moi
il était beaucoup trop mis en avant
après c'est un très bon joueur mais
qu'il a des moyennes il a déjà noté les
moyens parce que voilà c'est les trucs
que j'avais sous la main
17 points 4 rebonds 3 passes et un virus
un virus prosteel
il souffre du problème que quasiment
tous les jeunes de l'équipe on sait ce
[ __ ] de shoot à trois points quand les
pourcentages à trois points de l'équipe
et ils sont horriblement et pour
ce qu'ont annoncé être shooter il a des
grosses perfs à côté donc en fait c'est
bizarre parce que il ya certains soirs
on se croirait que c'est c'est le
nouveau le nouveau je ne sais qui est un
soir sur deux ou sur trois on le voit
pas sur le terrain on a l'impression
c'est lui qui porte la balle mais il
fait la passe et c'est tout et après le
jeu il laisse pas le jeu venir à lui il
prend pas les bouchoux qui fait pas les
bonnes décisions alors bien sûr ça
rentre dans le process d'amélioration
mais il ya du
gros progrès à faire sur ça et
ouais il y avait vraiment des soirées au
chaud tout c'est inégal complet
oui mais comme j'ai dit souffrent du
problème principal de cette équipe c'est
une suite appropriée
c'est compliqué chez les jeunes le tir à
trois points pour l'instant
j'en
rajoute heures de séries et
tricky contre contre mais ricco je crois
il commençait droit et 3,18 d'affilée de
du milieu du terrain et prend
complètement feu et daria temps mort il
en remettra plus un seul du match nous
imposer
ça vient plus d'une mauvaise sélection
de tirs que d'un problème de fuite ou de
mécanique ça sur les quelques matches
que j'ai vus des fois il en prend enfin
c'est juste pas le bon moment pour les
prendre
prayssas et les dessins des défauts de
l'inexpérience et la jeunesse s'est tu
croyais en fait on leur dit calmement
que tout est pour eux que
c'est comme quand vous mettez ballon à
des gosses op grande douleur dit fait
n'importe quoi et jouer va forcément ça
va ça va un moment donné ça va partir en
couille on va prendre des tirs à tire
larigot pourriez ben oui forcément j'ai
le même ring ding mengele kobe à chaque
fois donc ça pousse
les rebelles du coup c'est ce que moi
j'ai observé ces locations timing aussi
vraiment question de créer la séparation
le joueur adverse selon lui
c'est tout des problèmes qui sont
réglables ça ça m'inquiète vraiment à
pas pour le shopping et ça m'inquiète
vraiment passé tout des problèmes qui
sont réglables c'est un jeune qui
travaille dans la bonne direction donc
le côté attaque pour moi ces virements
pour une
quand je n'ai pas l'impression que jean
le joueur doit jouer beaucoup après bien
ramené à un billet à cause de dépenses
mais gaudet attaque je suis gay
est convaincu par cet écart que sont
steve bac parce que c'est un joueur qui
aime beaucoup le starbucks et ça rejoint
toute la question dans ce cas ludovic
chat qualités athlétiques c'est est ce
que vous trouvez que cette step back qui
prend craint vrai qu'avec son défenseur
moi je suis encore pas convaincu je
trouve que des fois il fait un nouveau
sur cette step starbucks et qu'en fait
c'est quand même le défenseur qui est
sur lui qui peut contester biture parce
qu'il n'a pas trahi et pas assez
tranchantes comme pas mais ça on s'en
sert majeure qui va créer sa séparation
pensait dextérité ballom sa puissance
mais pas par sa qualité
appliquée qui pour cela les comparaisons
il faut arrêter tout de suite je pense
qu'on sous code complètement l'athlète
explosif kate jane green faut arrêter de
dire que des gens comme ça on en voit
passer on n'en voit pas passer souvent
des mecs qui sont capables sur le
premier pas en termes de vivacité de
trancher comme ça génère 10 est pas un
athlète plus plus sur les antennes se
faisait vite échoue mais il a la
dextérité balle en main quand même pour
aller où il veut et pour avoir tiré sur
tout ça c'est surtout ça
vu qu'on parle de moi je suis croix
rousse et à pâques ça ça va prendre du
temps mais je croyais
vu qu'on parle d'athlètes messieurs la
transition est tout trouvé un athlète un
peu plus étrange est évalué c'est
l'australien tyson daniela raison
pense que là ça peut être clivant ce
beau les gens qu'ils ouvrent le bal
petite forêt
je commence je en plus je sais ce que
pensent certains par ici je suis moi je
suis assez haut sur une fin août pour
mars ont gardé mais mais j'aime beaucoup
ce que je trouve qu'il a un très bon qi
basket en défense comme en attaque il ya
des bonnes lectures de jeu et surtout
une bonne adaptation de son rôle et
c'est quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup
par un peu
la projection biais mais ouais c'est un
bon créateur joue qui gère bien le puis
quel rôle qui est quelque chose d'assez
important pour la projection aime bien
et surtout ce qui saute aux yeux je
pense qu'on le regarde offensivement
c'est sa finition préjudiciable au
niveau des flotteurs tout ce genre de
petit arsenal offensif qu'il a été très
développé je trouve et défensivement sur
la partie défensive je trouve horse ball
c'est plutôt intéressant comme j'ai dit
les biens les lectures les lignes de
passe par contre paintball je trouve
donc sur l'homme je trouve plus limité
il ya quelques flash mais je trouve que
c'est assez limité justement je trouve
qu'en fait quand on parlait des qualités
athlétiques moyenne de jaden ardid
pareil dizaine d'années je trouve
qu'athlétiquement ça manque de punch au
site pourtant il est assez lent
physiquement il a un physique un c'est
intéressant mais je trouve qu'il n'ya
pas un gros premier pas et au niveau de
ses qualités athlétiques où ça leur met
justement pour se créer son shoot par
exemple
donc voilà pour moi il y aura je pense
qu'il aura un rôle en nba de part son qi
basket hélas que j'étais à l'heure au
niveau de l'adaptation de son rôle je
trouve que c'est un salaire date un
joueur très intelligent qui pense au
collectif avant tout et je pense que
c'est le genre de joueur qui est très
facile à coacher je pense que tu peux
lui demander de jouer dans plusieurs
rôles différentes soit avec la balle
dans les mains shooter évolué il va pas
excellé là dedans mais il pourra faire
dans tous les roulis saura s'adapter se
rendre utile je pense
n
moi j'aime j'aime bien dyson j'étais
assez bas sur lui est ce que j'ai vu au
début d'année de la gelée revue germick
c'est ce que j'avais vu donc stadistes
étaient
aulas comme dumont et 19 où il était le
leader de l'équipe australienne
en fait pour moi il a pas un potentiel
fou fou lapin au plan 1 au plafond mais
je trouve qu'il a replancher il ses
pâtes et de riz blé choo t j'ai
intelligent closky
il il est intelligent il sait pas ses
dribbles et shooter ni défensivement il
fait les rotations et je fais des
efforts donc pour moi ça sera un joueur
de rotation nba je pense donc ce qu'ils
montrent déjà la argh night bah c'est
intéressant parce que je pense que c'est
c'est déjà être un joueur de complément
à côté de d2 porter de voile de l'équipe
de france qui sera en nba avec en plus
le fait que on l'a déjà vu qu'à
d'initiation pick-and-roll donc si
c'était avec l'australie tout cas ramené
de la question doivent cesser les tirs
on l'a pas absolument qu'ils tirent
mieux en fait une chose comme ça il sera
pas négatif sur le terrain là dessus
mais non j'ai bien dit je trouve que
c'est un joueur
facilement aux tables et en serbe dans
une rotation une vie interne
ben je sais que ton avis édité au
web
moi je suis je suis loin de ce que j'ai
vu je peux vu tous les matchs d'une aide
j'en ai vu le simple je crois pas
vraiment
encore son côté athlétisme côté défensif
savons pas très rapidement défendant le
pk loi au pays mais crée très vulnérable
au petit porteur de ballon je parlais de
mac mais claude en tant qu'union passer
sur le corps plusieurs fois j'ai vu
souvent suivent des porteurs de ballon
de derrière c'est toujours un peu risqué
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup la liste
urd j'aime beaucoup le le chien qui
démontre en jouant mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils tournent jour à la
roche j'aime parce que j'ai des choses
que j'aime chez lui
son sa vision en europe et de sa vision
en transition de la pauvre seulement
extraordinaire c'est ses
7 passes son absolution complètement
folle je les buffalos nantas de passe
adjé de nordic de enfin peut-être 80% du
terrain il a reçu droit d'un droit dans
la pochette
le
oui est ce que physiquement parlant il
va être assez solide pour prendre des
tirs un gardien est lié je le sais pas
j'ai ôté on vous avait parlé de son
son chat sa vision tient pas son pick
and roll mais moi je les trouvais
incroyablement et trévise j'ai trouvé
incroyable même que visible il va
falloir faire la bonne lecture une fois
ils vont faire la mauvaise lecture non
c'est pas une canaille
pour conter propres coéquipiers n'ont
peut-être que c'est la bataille kas et
la police que cela fait que ses
coéquipiers qui sont pas assez de niveau
mais je
les ai trouvés sous pli de recevoir ses
passes donc
c'est fini je suis si je comprends ce
que tu peux dire c'est que n'ai je pas
fleuri pour les leviers avec un peu le
manque de physique
je suis peut-être complètement notre
chat mais moi je ne l'étais pas
heureusement il n'a pas assez au cercle
commencé double pas bien trop tôt par
rapport aux serbes se trouve mieux ça ne
prend pas après faut pas oublier aussi
qu'il a il n'y a que 18 ans quand je
crois qu'il n'a pas encore 19 ans
mais mais mais je suis d'accord kabila
il ya un côté un peu soft dans sa façon
d'attaquer le salon là dessus je suis
d'accord
une
web totalement je suis d'helmut parce
que j'ai mon petit qui gueule à côté
pour dont
moi je pense que tyson il aspire à être
au niveau supérieur tu vois ce jour là
qui inactive la
20ème minute hormis
et
un mec qui peut tout faire sur un
terrain qui sera pas lite effectivement
qui est très intelligent limites et
athlétiquement je rejoins un peu de tout
ce qui a été dit
voilà quand coca demandé aux collégiens
ouais ouais mais le mois le
pire le
des genevois ghafir c'est ça des zones
inspire
j'ai
commencé à attaquer les sous ministres
avec des enfants de sa chronique après
s'être a décidé d'être un peu plus un
peu plus développé et ne faisait de
xanax
[Musique]
c'est que du plaisir c'est que du
plaisir et
voilà c'est un joueur qui fait tout bien
mais voilà qui est qui a des qualités
athlétiques sont trop limitées pour être
un rôle important de bâle qui fut dira
juste sur le terrain donc toujours un
joueur intéressant dans ton équipe mais
d'ailleurs si je dis pas de bêtises
porteur de balle second mmo ni knight
s'est jamais lui quasiment quiero très
rarement qui remonte la balle non c'est
pas évident et pas vraiment dans ce rôle
là après est-ce qu'il semblait je pense
pas
pouvoir avoir remporté tant de mal pris
mais il a été avec l'australie provost
du positif et du négatif
du puzzle est ce que j'ai vu de lui
d'inciter ses coûts du monde 19.19 du
peu de lettres que j'ai vu quand
la ligue annoncé sa signature nine
nights s'avère prometteur
même si ben mince avait pas l'air d'être
exceptionnel non plus ça aurait eu l'air
très très très prometteur on nous l'a
vendu fin du mois le compte us de
twitter et les officiels de la ligue moi
quand j'aurai parler de dieu d'énergie
ils m'ont tout de suite mon tout de
suite vendu un bon jeune bonne mentalité
qui va pouvoir
un peu avoir un rôle d'énergiser mai
des heurts qui va
qui va tout faire qui va être un peu aux
landais
s'est pas totalement ce qu'il en est
mais j'espère qu'on va pour se
rapprocher comme ce serait une bien
messieurs on a fait le tour sur des
scènes de liesse on va passer alain
jeunes bouchons et la nar jacques
beauchamp ci
est peut-être des trois celui qui fait
la meilleure saison
angeli ça c'est le plus vieux si michael
foster n'existait pas
non je peux pas être objectif
il est seul contre
quatre objectifs avec marjane motion
c'est mon chouchou sa défaite l'an
dernier mois j'avais combine gala cette
année c'est là cette année c'est
beauchamp enfin
c'est peut-être le celui qui bat oui
effectivement c'est plus vieux il amène
deux ans mais
c'était celui qui a le plus de chance de
pas d'aller loin mais de faire et je
pense la plus longue carrière
je pense c'est un
sortie de banque en sortie de banc ça
peut être une bonne une bonne pièce
après avoir commencé comment il se
développe après s'il est drafté ou non
mais s'il est drafté franchement ça peut
être super joueur le super joueur de
rotation même biais quoi il peut faire
une longue carrière mais je pense
c'est qu'ils marchent d'un bouchon comme
voir comme type de voir
je suis trop encore difficile à définir
je trouve que c'est un excellent slasher
c'est un mec qui déjà capable de finir
d'être demain qui a un vrai athlète qui
est explosif qui a acquis et crafty près
du panier qui capable de changer de
direction en l'air c'est un défenseur
que je trouve très intéressante sur le
hockey sera la façon de tankessé le
contact alors effectivement voit qu'il
est plus vieux mais voilà il est
vraiment capable de soutenir plusieurs
postes de tir des mecs plus grand que
lui et de tenir latéralement des mecs
plus petit que lui
la question principale qui se pose ça va
être son tir on arrivera au monde et les
pourcentages ou tirs extérieurs et je
crois qu'ils sont qui sont assez légers
mais je suis assez l'aller 2-3 pourtant
ouais voilà c'est ça c'est vraiment
dégueulasse on est monté à 2 5% mais
l'an dernier alors fera me corriger mais
je crois qu'il jouait dans une sorte de
choco
et du coup il ajouté a quasiment 35% à 3
ans il en avait pris je crois 59 sur 150
est à 9 9% gélules ouais c'est peut-être
ça peut-être c'est le nombre de tirs qui
la miss 39 euros 149 mais voilà on est
dans ce style là je trouve que jon
lajoie de la mi distance il passe
efficace après on voit que toutes les
situations stif l'auteur parce qu'il
fallait pas mal de mettre des flotteurs
il ya vraiment très peu touché à ce
niveau là donc je suis pas encore
déterminé sources financières mais je
les les jeux léa c'est au moins de
bouchons honnêtement j'y crois assez
forte
elle
oui ce que j'entends c'est vrai mais en
même temps c'est normal et à deux ans de
plus les envolées beaucoup plus simple
que les autres donc ok il est plus
propre il est plus près défensivement
mais
c'est plus facile aussi il est donc il a
un parcours un peu différent il a il
avait dit qu il a refusé la d15 nsia
parce qu'il ya des petits soucis et donc
et après l'été s'entraîner ils savent ce
qui fait que c'est quoi c'est un 2003 ou
2008 nous en 2003 de mémoire c'est 2000
ou 2001 on dit que la scène analysé en
2003 par exemple scouts en 2004 donc
voilà c'est totalement normal qu'ils
soient plus forts sur un terrain de
basket aujourd'hui et la cour de
progression ne sera donc pas la même
chose mais par contre pour soulever je
suis vraiment d'accord facile à insérer
dans une rotation n'diaye se défendre en
terme de polyvalence sur les ailes
attaque bien les clauses out ce très bon
slasher d'un couple loin du ballon de
ceux ci c'est le 3,6 tire pas à trois
points en quatre jeunes tout ça va être
compliqué pour moi parce que le mi
distance tout ça va pas lui demander à
une vieillerie pas assez fort pour qu'on
une bande-son donc
c'est vraiment son achat de 100 tirs à
trois points je comprends qu on ouvre on
le voit dans un modèle de tuer nier 7ème
8ème une rotation si le trois points pas
là c'est plus complexe
mais
moi j'adore son attaque de clausade oui
je m'entends bien
oui oui c'est moi dans les terriers un
peu de temps à 0 jatte
j'adore voir jon boscia
fait lever les gars de leurs pieds
c'est complètement fou il est d'avis il
attaque dans les angles penchée vers
l'avant inhumain il a vraiment cet hp
jurent ils ne maîtrisent vraiment très
très bien
défensivement aussi c'est un gars qui
est très grave pas si simple quoique 200
lits qui deux ans plus vieux donc
physiquement plus près mais il est
capable au fait quel rôle de se rendre
vraiment très très petit qui passait
derrière les écrans qui sont glauques et
beaucoup de il semble avoir beaucoup
plus de maturité face à son rôle de
comprendre justement sur le peu
d'énergie qui doit qui nous a touchés
échanges et la géométrie du jeu chasser
le porteur de balle il est
magnifiquement bien le 6e quelque chose
qui façonne son tir s'est créé là ça
démarre lentement le le le geste très
très lent je sais pas qu'est ce qui
change beaucoup de sens mais jusqu'à
dégager c'est à dire
et ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup parce que
oui comme diane
chauffard or il va falloir qu'il ya eu
deux tirs à trois points un joueur qui
se débrouille quand même pas mal
allenby avec un tir à trois points
kitsch et qui s'est déjà stand validé
dans un rôle similaire mais je crois que
physiquement et athlétiquement par la
mort john plus peu plus au plafond que
justin a validé mon année sans sneijder
au mur falloir absolument quitter
c'est grand le débat et je pense qu'on
voit de lui c'est strict de ce que j'ai
fait quelques ça fait quelques années
que je suis pom à new york les red
bull à chaque match mais ce qu'ils
attendent pour son os 3.1 indien depuis
trois ans c'est pas l'argent de bouchons
josh d'abord justin valider son plafond
ça va être un jour ci est capable de
tirer à trois points sur votre joie de
tous ceux qui attaquent les clauses
aussi vraiment très bien mais peut-être
poids avec une physique aussi aussi des
40 que me donne mon chien qui fait
kiffer qui fait exploser des gars comme
sur un champ de bataille on dirait que
les gars ils sont toujours des miennes
dit faux qu'est ce que tu as remarqué
chez lui peut-être défensivement de plus
comment projette sur les capable de
switcher qui avait le premier
bassin offensivement je pense que vous
avez faits touchant ce que défensivement
et c'est ça qui va être très intéressant
dans sa projection aime bien ça capte et
c'est à défendre et surtout à pouvoir
défendre plusieurs postes pour moi il
peut défendre deux voire trois postes en
tout cas en j league après en dépendra
évidemment des machos mais oui je pense
que ce côté en fait il a un profil très
nba je trouve ce genre délié longiline
très athlétique polyvalent défense sa
soeur ça plaira toujours à une franchise
nba après je suis contraint et forcé de
rejoindre tous que tout ce qu'on dit les
autres sur sur le shoot donc il aura
enfin son shoot et et à
réussir à voir une certaine régularité
au tir c'est ce qui fera la différence
entre être un septième huitième homme et
être en forme au fin fond du banc en nba
est ce qu'on a fait le tour sur la
remise en jeu bouchons pour le sont bien
chez les chiens de rennes le micro je
sens un dernier détail tchad à shadow's
tale en effet justin hallyday avait 34
35 33 et depuis quitté à un diamant il a
ans j'étais dans l'erreur
mais il apprend deux ans
[Musique]
avec
les digues c'est les tatouages ou en
forme des toiles la chose aisée poule ça
c'est très mauvais si sa c2 est trop
longue dégueulasse et là ça fait très
cassos
qu'on peut ou que j'ai pas dit lequel la
team il a vraiment une belle attraction
physique et la tête où je me dis hou là
là est ce que lui est ce que lui c'est
un bosseur ou pas quoi vraiment l'air
un moteur non pour moi c'est par exemple
sur la tête ne vont pas pour la tête son
parcours le monde parce que il a galéré
il a eu un parcours pas facile je crois
que nos
lycées même famille allemand s'était
passé un peu la kiss qui galère un peu
dans circuit secondaire voire tercea qui
se retrouvent starter honig night même
si voilà c'est normal qu'ils soient
starter ni nike parce qu'un projet de
mettre en avant je trouve que
franchement c'est ainsi un bel exemple
que bah je peux rater un petit peu
peut-être des choses au lycée raté des
bourses il avait des gros freins de
mémoire je vais aller vérifier mais il
avait des grosses offres de mémoire
c'est pas fait pour diverses raisons
bras ligne mais pas fait mon annoncé que
l'ue allait même se présenter à la draft
directement après l'avoir vu son nom
beauchamp pour 2020 2022 mais 2020-2021
pardon mais je trouve que voilà sur
l'éthique de travail je pense que ça va
aller chercher là où je rejoins à
l'anoci c'est sur le côté
enfin moi j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'ils accèdent qui comprend et qu'il
accepte son rôle
dans la g-league là où justement il
pourrait se dire je suis plus âgé que
les autres prospects pourquoi moi
j'aurais pas loin d'avoir plus de
ballons plus de tickets shoots et en
fait comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et il comprend son rôle il sait
que c'est un energizer est pas un
créateur pour les autres ou un bol et
leur évite et et ouais il accepte le
fait très bien et ça pour moi sous forme
de deux d'intelligence et de qi basket
alors les zones afp washington
washington state florida state oregon
state
la 28e sur le big band pour l'instant
après pour le big board ces patients
devraient produire je l'avais pas me
j'avais mis aucun prospects digue knight
et je l'avais justifié en disant que je
voulais voir au moins sept huit matches
maintenant c'est fait je pourrais le
refaire donc ça explique aussi qu'il
soit peut-être un peu plus bas c'est
parce que j'ai aucun incendie part
voilà hardy pareil
j'en ai pas d'autre au premier tour
n'est ces deux là donc ça descend
forcément par rapport à la moyenne c'est
ma faute mais bat
messieurs là on va sortir les gants de
boxe j'ai l'impression
parler des cas complexes
c'est assez complexe à l'est de michael
foster dans l'est ce qui est drôle c'est
que mon service ça fait quel complexe et
les boss
parler de michael foster junior et de
fond
comment parler que de michael for search
junior
pierre vu que tu as la parole tu la
gardes vu que tu est sont presque son
agent ce soir
et après
ça y'a pas de soucis je suis préparé
j'ai le casque et des gants
et un agenda qui fait qu'on se mec qui
m'ont qui nous désole
en défense je vous la corde c'est une
quiche une vraie ce qu'on y
met en attaque le mec depuis que
certains
que je ne nommerai pas se sont amusés à
se [ __ ] de sa gueule sur la
conversation comme il est quand même à
quatre matchs il est quatre il est quand
même à quatre matchs en vingt dix au
minimum avec au minimum 5 passes
donc je n'ai pas eu des ondes négatives
qui vu son arrivée je ne sais rien mais
il a capté il a dû capter ça qu'on a de
l'affluence
le mec il est criminellement sous-estimé
c'est à dire que en moyenne sur les
sur le peu de matches qu'ils ont fait
pour l'instant c'est 15 points 8 rebonds
2 passes 2 et 2 contres en
si jamais c'était marge de beauchamp qui
ferait ça on dirait roi [ __ ] le mec
super voilà on dira [ __ ] super le mec
mais que ça y va être premier tour de
draft
il va jouer en nba c'est sûr etc mais là
vu que c'est là que la tête de con la
tête de turc de l'équipe là on dit web
au pôle meilleur double oui
c'est bien mignon là dessous de la gare
de pékin mais bon là pour moi c'est pas
justifié le mec qui pour moi il dit
quoi jouer à la draft moi je pense que
l'équipe si les choisir la drache pense
que l'équipe qui qui le prend un
célèbre après bien sûr seine paris comme
n'importe quelle joie comme n'importe
quel joueur mais pour moi c'est un pari
qui peut marcher et si jamais un jour il
arrive à faire un truc un billet je
serai le premier à aller sur twitter
tous mentionnaient avec le real
avec toutes
les atrocités qui va être dit dans les
dix prochaines minutes et vous
recherchez des chers mais bien comme il
faut des petites crottes de nez mais
deux médailles mais que de temps en
temps tu as un v10 une crotte de nez
parce que je suis convaincu qu'il peut
reproduire ça au niveau au niveau nba on
va donner la parole à un kit fond pour
montrer notre notre bonne volonté
alors comme vous attendez moi je suis un
peu moins vous est encore offrir ce mémo
non moi je suis vraiment pas fan j'ai du
mal à le projeter l'histoire et je
trouve que défensivement où mathieu
c'est peut-être le seul pôle logement
pire en fait il
ya j'ai l'impression de voir en tant que
fans des celtics pierre savate ramène ça
vous rappeler des souvenirs en défense
j'ai l'impression parfois de voir qu'en
terre et encore et encore je dis que
quand air sur les pick and roll des fois
ils sont mais il s'en sort mieux dans la
défense en pick and roll est
catastrophique même la défense de
manière générale et d'ailleurs sa
cellule frustrant quand on voit le le
profil physique parce que c'est un
joueur qui est quand même assez à ces
baraques et et même la protection du
cercle et enfin je trouve très limités
par rapport à son physique j'ai en tête
un match contre l'équipe des kings
où il s'est fait martyriser le paraguay
où il se fait martyriser par mbia
scrutin
le séminaire du guerre à jouer clients
précédents portraits mm prince km je
trouve qu'ils défensivement c'est
catastrophique
et offensivement alors il quelques
flashs au shoot extérieur mais je trouve
la mécanique faut
savoir a fait rire la mécanique ça fait
une catapulte qui part loin dans la tête
comme ça l'homme c'est assez étrange qui
choisit jamais rappelé le choc entre
leur jeu j'achète pas vraiment le foot
et du coup quand on enlève la défense -
le foot du coup quel genre de profil
en tant que pivot en nba dans ce cas la
cdu rim runner et protecteur mais
comment la dir est une protection
aux éditions du siècle y'en a pas encore
qu'un encore que franchement mais il a
des bonnes soeurs après serment c'est
toujours le genre de truc l ema qui
défendent pas mais que des bonnes sato
compte c'est une
aberration mais en fait tout quasiment
tous les comptes qui fait c'est sûr des
sur des retours défensifs il s'est joint
le mec l'ex boxeur la
ccc soit des retours défensifs contre
attaque soit ça s'est il s'est passé et
retour et bim contre mais c'est
c'est aberrant d'avoir une défense aussi
aussi pauvre mais du coup dans la
projection aime bien c'est compliqué
parce que comme on l'a dit défensivement
on n'est pas assez bon pour être
protecteur de cercle offensivement
personnellement j'achète pas son shoot
donc compliqué de le projeter dans un
rôle de stretch fine
alors il peut faire des belles choses en
attaque poste bas
il a quand même des mains plutôt
correcte et une bonne finition poste bas
mais à voir que ça
je trouve ça un peu light pour essayer
de faire une carrière une pièce surtout
dans la vie actuelle pour un pivot si je
peux juste un truc après je me tais à
tout jamais c'est quand même le mec qui
a le meilleur pourcentage de trois
points dès
jeudi soir
sur un échantillon tellement faible
empreinte un match
pour
défendre c'est une grosse merde il
arrivera jamais en nba j'aurais essayé
dit
on va écouter à la ddt
pour moi c'est là tout le problème
pas trois points s'ils croyaient les
trois points je peux acheter michael
foster ci prend des trois points parce
que je me dis
pourquoi ça serait pas pas bobby portis
où tu vois un genre de
l'intérieur qui est pas qui a besoin de
jouer qu'un protecteur de cercle
mekhissi tir 5,6 x 30 ans par match et
voix sur quinze minutes bon allez je
peux essayer de régler un peu puissant
si jamais il ya un switch sur un plus
petit peu futur proche du panier mais la
menace principale restera propre mon
problème c'est quoi c'est qui prend un
tir à trois points par match donc tous
les autres tirs qui fait la nba les aura
pas il pourra pas faire pour moi
j'espère ce genre de choses
offensivement son problème pour moi il
n'est pas vraiment de talent ou de ce
que je pense qu'il a un vrai talent
offensif je pense que s'il vient du
profil qu'il est l'association déception
que j'ai sur les gonaïves cette année
c'est que j'aimerais qu'il fasse qu'il
fasse prendre plus de trois points
vraiment fait le tir à trois points
c'est pas un petit pick n pop et puis
des choses comme ça qu'il puisse dire à
propos et défensivement par contre
c'est mental je trouve plus qu'autre
chose il ne sait pas défendre un pic
noir il ne comprend pas quoi faire
taguée où allez vous regarder il ne
comprend pas donc ils tombent donc
comment faire ton masque et ce en nba
plus de 20 minutes par match pour moi
c'est impossible je dis pas que le draft
pas franchement je vous faut arrêter ces
il est né en 2003 et si je le en fait je
peux le draft et où je le prends je le
ramène en j league en fait pendant deux
ans avec mon staff et je le fait de
prendre des pick n pop à trois points et
j'essaye de lui apprendre à défendre
d'europe moi j'essaye de ne pas prendre
parce que nick knight défend beaucoup je
trouve peu en drop alors c'est ça switch
on nous demande parfois de un peu
regardé prend les décisions j'aimerai
qu'on facilite son appréhension et je
pense que allégée des g2 pic au deuxième
tour en
on adore tous pleins de joueurs on
regarde tous les initiés on a tous
pleins de gens qu'on aurait peut-être
drafté mais bon je me dis c'est en 2003
il ya un certain talent mais c'est pas
un saint prosper premier tour non mais
c'est mais juste il n'est pas il faut
qu'il change son jeu offensivement pour
aller à une belle chance charlene excuse
moi il fait beaucoup penser à un joueur
qui a été drafté au deuxième tour il ya
deux ans et régis péri ouais un peu dans
le même jour de voir et que les mêmes
qualités un peu d'effort s'offrant si
bourbon ça peut dribbler mais
défensivement ça fait la circulation va
les mecs qu'on aimerait qu'ils fassent
une chose que du fight club du post up
parce qu'ils le feront les le front par
une bille est complètement complètement
récupéré n'a pas réussi cette transition
d'ailleurs pour l'instant monétaire il
s'agrippe les derniers dire je
m'agenouille alors si j'arrive mais
petit on est à l'honneur c'est du perche
c'est mal
je reviens moi je pense que c'est fait
pour moi je suis juste déçu de ça en
plus de faire à trois points on les
fasse plus en prendre parce que comme un
ciment il a un jeu 3 lancinant font
alors que je trouve que son tirer bat
affreux comme l'adulte m'a dit pierre
avant il ya les blés pourcentage je suis
d'accord avec mes du point
mais il va aussi pas beaucoup ce rallye
sport il à ce profil de c'est vraiment
un rôle qui pourrait fonctionner à une
vieillesse et du stretch fort ou
straight five avec la côte et nuit un
protecteur de cercle sur une quinzaine
de minutes par match parce que ça ça
peut le faire mais il faut qu'ils
changent faisait
et qu'il se compose de fun bowling
terminer sur lui aïe je vais être juste
et je suis un jour galant avec alana
dessus il doit changer son jeu quand on
doit changer son jeu je pense que c'est
la clé ici parce que au poste bol il se
retrouve toujours en prise sur ce je
joue pas sa voix dans la vie moderne
tout à un très très haut qi basket sécu
basket nomme michael fois sur le port
elle serait toujours appris à dolo pris
la 3 il s'en sort souvent par sa
longueur parce qu'il pût grain plus gros
plomb que tout le monde j league mais ça
sera pas le cas à une bulle et mais ce
que je suis d'accord avec alan si le
trait et
est vraiment pas
un problème quand on peut régler la
catapulte comme vous dites voir le
problème le cas d'apple souvent c'est
des joueurs qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
force physique qu'on appelle g qui
compense en
anticipant le ballon plus loin kawai
leonard avis est il réglé ce problème là
on bosse amplifié ces tests très très
simple la règle il faut juste une plus
grande économie de mouvements
l'entretenir fait oui moi je vois mal
une fois ce tueur jouer en temps ou en
espèces de bois du poète et ce à quatre
ou cinq points par match c'est pas un
choix le premier dos mais c'est pas
c'est pas perdu mais juste ciel arrêter
de jouer au post ben ali
non seulement il pas bon en défensive
mais enfin en attaque qui l'issue les
possessions son équipe avec les prises à
deux les prix la fois
conclure rapidement ouais je pense que
vous avez quasiment tous dit le truc de
michael foster du nord c'est qui se
prend pour un jour qu'il l'est pas je
pense que lui point de lui dans sa tête
c'est une sorte de d'ulysse roundup il
aime beaucoup de riz blé l'aiment
beaucoup fait sa pub où je poste bas est
en réalité ce imputant aux marquis
spelman ça mais que kim et des très très
très bon écran qui a dû toucher près du
panier qui monte du pur et simple très
très très bon opposant d'écran et les
petits de m 0,30 par beaucoup de pivot
mais très très très petit et c'est pas
un monstre aquatique verticale non plus
à intégrer dans une équipe voilà je
pense que lui faut qu'ils se revoient ce
qu'il est fauconnet une équipe nba le
définissent très rapidement son rôle est
ce qui va devoir de venir et qu'on crée
quelque chose de positif la traîne par
rapport à lui on tue t'aime beaucoup
tapé sur un penny mois il rappelle un
peu près tout ça tu sois en a et b n'y
trouve comment le mettre en avant
totalement
simplifier les choses et en même temps
c'est normal et sort deux lycées y voit
là et a eu une crise fret en arizona ils
avaient tous les ballons et c'est normal
c'est un ajustement pour lui il ya un
peu moins qu'elle n'ait que peu de chose
par exemple la compagnie
je mets ces deux joueurs tu vois même
pas ses dribbles de shooter à une taille
qui fait qu'en nba ça va être compliqué
donc je peux trouver autre chose pour
proposer et enfin pendant deux trois
fans bobines de film bowling moi j'aime
bien être sûr bijoux pour ça que je les
attends je vais te mettre au chaud mais
sur 2 3 flash que j'ai vu je me rappelle
comme si c'était parce que comme l'asie
ou vendait des débuts très très peu il
avait commis table gonzague a en fait il
a des comics pour aller faire le choix
de digg like je pense que dans un an il
en australie très honnêtement dans notre
grille est un peu à la à l'accueil photo
mais où ado thalamas courmayeur ce genre
de jour là mais franchement je trouve
qu'à sa taille il
j'ai trouvé une dextérité bas-normands
plutôt intéressante je demande à voir en
fait je demande à revoir je n'ai pas de
froid mais je demande à revoir
puisque s'inspirent les autres femmes
osagi moi c'est pas celui que j'ai assez
suis donc je pars il ne rien dire plutôt
que de dire des âneries mais par contre
je suis la brosse à la louise match
moi je n'ai pas vu beaucoup non ils
jouent pas beaucoup joué joue pas bien
il ya un côté parce qu'il a il a un côté
très loving you mais c'est assez
intéressant de l'agilité qu'il n'a pas
encore à son physique et l'empathie
beaucoup d intérêt dans l'équipe parce
que c'est même beau même si les jeunes
etc c'est moins bonne des intérieurs qui
aide à l'équipe même les vieux font plus
autant que lui on a vu sur certaines
possessions où il n'est pas vraiment un
défense c'est toujours pareil le gros
problème de cette équipe les deux gros
problèmes de l'équipe c'est la défense
est trop con il perdait d y perdre des
matches qui perdent des mêmes des quarts
temps parce que le brent ont été oubliés
obligé de rappeler des temps morts pour
leur dire les mecs concentrez vous
concentrez vous le match c'est aussi en
défense et là bizarrement pendant de
3000 ça va mieux mais après ça
redevienne bordel ils sont pas la gagner
des matches franchement si non mais si
reconnaît il sera pas là pour gagner des
matches mais il ya une même si en grand
compétiteur qui doivent être tous
pousser chacun il ya un minimum de
fierté à voir
le
match ça se gagne aussi en défense et si
vous défendez pas on a vu d'un match
cette nuit
cette nuit contre les longues il en est
les mecs ils ont tenu tous troisième
quart temps et après me troisième un au
revoir plus de défense puis défense du
tout et des fêtes de 20.3
88 cents à moins d'être comme ça j'ai vu
ce matin quand j'ai fait mon résumé mais
vraiment il n'y a pas eu de
ya pas eu de défense du tout dans la fin
du match et ça fait peur parce que l'on
se dit merde si ces joueurs là qui
veulent essayer d'aller respirer à taper
du pied ornans falloir qu'il ya un gros
step up défensif parce que l'offensif
ils l'ont ils n'ont pas le tir de loin
pour l'instant mais ça s'est amélioré
mais défensifs c'est un gros axe de
progression qui va falloir bosser dans
toute l'équipe parce que il n'y a pas
grand monde qui défend laisser les vieux
souvent qu'ils sont obligés de rentrer à
la place des jeunes pour essayer de
maintenir un peu le match à fond et ne
pas se prendre une branlée montage avant
les différences physiques
des joueurs qui sont très très jeune
donc forcément au bout d'un moment avec
naturel du match le camp les chocs
physiques et subit de plus en plus
plumassière d'entre eux ont tous suivi
donc c'est aussi
surtout content
et parce que j'ai une question là-dessus
tout début pour le 3e tir à trois points
et je suis très rapidement c'est un
problème de cette année au global je
pense pas que ça va leur porter très
préjudice a dit pas très nature et c'est
parce que tous les gros tireurs de la
draft l on pensera que les vieux stade
face à max question pensent à baldwin
signaux fondés très mauvaise fin
mauvaise saison aux tirs à trois points
5 sur 7 des spécialistes donc on a une
cuvée au général qui a du mal à mettre
ses tirs extérieurs
messieurs on va se projeter dans aller
un an et demi scout henderson on l'a
évoqué du temps d'en parler en long en
large et en travers cet homme mérite ce
jeune homme est
à 17 ans je n'ai pas de bêtises est ce
que c'est le danger numéro 1 pour victor
wanyama pour la première place de la
draft 2023 [ __ ] j'ai alors j'ai envie
de me tabasser par ce que j'ai vu donc
le déroulé des missions du 6 mai merci
qui oui mbi
et j'ai tapé sur google wimbee prospects
et je trouvais
ça je suis pas sûr si les américains
l'appellent en fait c'est ça c'est le
moment que générique je vais dire des
zones et ça tourne mon gamin ça c est
pour eux c'est wendy c'est pour ça que
j'espère c'est marcus camby à l'envers
qu'est ce que c'est la même route terre
pro wendy
et vraiment je savais plus où mettre
mais vous donc du coup je me sens
tellement bête si vous savez
toutefois je te lance
une personne je suis précède danton à
rennes là dessus ce que je sais qu'il
aime beaucoup
de ce que j'ai vu joueur très athlétique
si les pages où les premiers matches
je suis d'avis de ne pas petit protocole
kobe je crois ouais voilà donc il a le
moins de matches que que la plupart mes
joueurs très athlétiques très rapide
tout à l'heure on en parlait de certains
qui comparait déjà dan hardy hadjal and
green je trouve que s'il y en a un qui
ressemble un peu plus à john green sais
plus ce que tant de personnes sur le
côté athlétique
donc voilà le joueur très athlétique un
premier pas qui pour moi est élite une
grosse capacité sur tout ce que je
trouve très intéressant c'est qu'il ya
une grosse capacité à mettre la pression
sur le cercle ça c'est quelque chose qui
va être hyper intéressant sa projection
nba et contrairement à souvent qu'on
voit ce genre de profil a justement
parlé avec elle dès mardi john green on
a concédé des scoreurs soulist
scouts anderson il a déjà les making
très développé et je trouve ça hyper
intéressant pour un jeune de son âge
comme tu l'as dit il encore 17 ans et
c'est enfin moi je trouve ça hallucinant
d'avoir cette capacité de vouloir allait
scorer mais d'avoir la lucidité et la
compréhension du jeu depuis basket pour
créer du jeu pour les autres stage là
c'est assez hallucinant je trouve après
sur les côtés un peu moins
glorieux on va dire il ya la défense
défensivement en fait je sais pas je
sais pas c'est un manque d envie parce
que les qualités athlétiques et âmes je
sais pas c'est un manque d'envié ou de
cui défensive mais ce serait assez
étonnant je sais pas franchement la
défense je ne sais pas et le tir japon
que c'est un mal qui touche un peu tout
le monde où je trouve qu'il est très
irrégulier lui aussi mais la mécanique
et est bonne et pourcentage aux lancers
francs sont plutôt encourageants chevaux
dont le tir je peux l'acheter parmi ces
défauts de tir je peux l'acheter la
défense
j'achète un peu moins après je préfère
le rappeler on parle d'un gamin qui à 17
ans qui affronte des joueurs déjà de
raft et expérimenté donc tous les
défauts qu'on voit son shoot sa
compréhension du genre défense pour moi
ce sont des défauts qui sont tout à fait
normaux à ce stade de sa carrière être
sont en développement
ben
côté de ces aides j'adore j'adore ce
côté personne je crois pas que ce soit
une menace pour leurs ailerons une
victoire d'anyama parce qu'un joueur de
six pieds trois pouces qui fait ce
qu'elle veut faire une bannière bois
tuer
j'en ai jamais vu peut-être d'abord
kareem abdul-jabbar on parle on parle je
crois de prospects historique en béton
une bannière mametz coutelle de chalon
parle de prospects à la position où il
joue va pas une baignoire j'en ai pas vu
beaucoup qui avaient des outils aussi
poli à l'âge oscille où est ce qu'ils
leur petite histoire c'est un excellent
joueur de pick and roll moi je trouve
que c'est de
loin la même joie de pékin londres sont
énervés les écrins prend les bonnes
décisions
aussi ce quelque chose pour moi est très
très important que plusieurs joueurs ne
développent jamais c'est à dire 1 go to
move c'est une réaction de l'action de
jeu qui va fonctionner pour l'époque
qu'est ce qui arrive pour au scrutin du
sun sea son drive avec la main droite il
à la rapidité il les changements dictés
à 6 dans le premier pas pour que ça
fonctionne à chaque coup et pour ça ça
ça change la géométrie jules sauf à
changer la manière dont jean todt
défendent à un billet comme ailleurs il
le réussit tellement avec facilité
angélique moi je crois qu'il veut
réussir avec facilité en nba aussi la
défense il 17 ans ça m'inquiète pas ils
jouent comme des hommes il se fait en
portiers répare des écrans il va se
faire au portier répand dans le petit
livre à votre comprendre moi j'allais
ici à six pieds le procès ce que mme à
semble que s'il me semble qu'il y aura
plus que c'est ce que je me trompe
puisque a grandi depuis moi j'ai cru en
moi mais
moi je te dis je rigole mais
mais moi ça mais qui a pour effet plus
amusant et
il a 17 ans et le 17 avril et du 3
février donc il va avoir 18 tables et
pau vont ensuite en une semaine bonne
foi et scouts mais
athlétique côté qu'aux côtés
polissage
de taling au shoot comme à la base comme
l anep également j'ai rarement vu un
joueur qui était aussi complet aussi
poli que ce soit pour un joueur de 17
ans ça va facilement le numéro de loin
de me battre
tout le monde attend
numéros et le numéro numéro deux chez
pas il ya deux jumeaux que tu devrais
aller voir je pense parce que très
honnêtement les jumeaux thompson ou 6 on
aimerait qu'on dit a trait aux
militants s'ils sont pas d'avoir 2022
mettez les mois dans la 2022 parce que
je ne sais pas
mais je pense que je suis pas précis aux
arrêts amène scout c'est que dire que
dire de plus que ce qui a été dit ce qui
est dit par tous
moi j'avais plus j'ai vu jouer une fois
aux red bull mais déjà je m'étais dit
mais qu'est ce que cette fois c'est
absolument n'importe quoi et en fait ce
que je trouve de souvent on en avant les
qualités athlétiques ça sert à quoi des
qualités athlétiques pour des mecs comme
jam auront tous des maîtresses acer pour
mettre à faciliter la prise de décision
parce qu'en fait ils arrivent tellement
a créé de l'ecal pour ses adversaires et
arrive tellement à se mettre dans des
bonnes dispose mission pas qu'ensuite ça
facilite la passe souvent c'est pas les
moeurs fasseur les meilleurs processeurs
mais secret de la passivité scouts j'ai
l'impression que il a même pas besoin de
ce secret cette facilité il a quand même
ce sens du jeu capacité à faire toutes
les passes et en plus il a un premier
pas vient volcan le premier pas qui fait
qu' il facilite la vie donc franchement
c'est j'ai l'impression que là il a 17
ans il va au cirque comme il veut en
transition sur ou sur ou sur jeu placé
il sait faire les renversements les
ti-cats haute main droite main gauche
passe à une main demain vrai problème
c'est le tir à trois points mais quand
un peu comme un jour de 17 ans qui prend
du coulobre c'est normal alors oui ça va
s'améliorer je pense à ces échantillons
sont petits mais c'est un des prospects
porteur de balle les plus
impressionnants de ces cinq dernières
années franchement je pense
g j'aime bien la question ça
on va elby plancher ce serait quoi
sachant qu'on n'aime pas trop les
comparaisons mais c'est le nom des
sentiments
structure
parce que la facilité et ce qu'on entend
sur moi j'ai vu une campagne faisons sur
twitter c'est derrick rose a
classiquement je l'avais du
tournoi moi je trouve qu'il fait très
doux et nous y
attaquer cercle c'est vrai
j'adorerais que ça devienne
c'est très peu probable mais j'adorerais
que ça devienne un joueur type démarre
de rose ring il n'est pas du tout de
prêts destinés mais avec le la capacité
d'aller aux autres rêves qui là après
moi je vous ai marre des roses à
l'époque raptor inquiète un athlète de
ouf
les gens qui veulent des mordus
actuellement ses compagnes peut-être
l'adulte et rosanara tort
je ne dirais pas ça moi j'ai pas la
ville et l'oeil expert de la dette ou
ski et prospects etc parce que moi tout
ce qui est prospects j'y connais pas
grand chose même si j'ai essayé de m'y
intéresser un peu c'est pas mon domaine
d'expertisé pour ça que depuis tout à
l'heure je vous laisse un peu plus
parler et comment le du coucher un peu
plus en retrait parce que j'ai pas
vraiment cet oeil là un peu plus avisés
on va dire moi je mets un avis très
brutes sur les jours
et c'est pour ça que moi je peux
j'aimerais qu'il devienne dans le dans
le drive dans la capacité à à
aller finir au cercle ou md rosen un peu
un peu toronto derozan toronto qui
arrache tout cas qui arrache tout est
bon peut-être pas avec le médecin ce qui
va avec mais où l agressivité au cercle
constante aux
cds qui monte quand même pas mal j'ai
apprécié on
l'a vu mettre de sacré poster des
tubes
tapis scouts henderson
highlights vous allez trouver des
défauts déjà c'est sympa
il a fait des grosses perf au scoring
vie il met un poster par match
moi je passais son plancher de lausanne
ch points loeb je crois que ce quota
nous sommes peut être un prospect qui
voit de lune et y en a
mais c'est un truc peut-être qu'on est
surévalué mais il a le charisme des
superstars ya un truc où tu que tu mets
ton mind je regarde et le fait tout de
suite tu vois scouts henderson moi tu
choisis beaucoup de mal à évaluer et et
daniel dit bouchons etc parce que même
si je veux la regarder peut très vite
mon oeil il va sur henderson et qu'il a
le ballon c'est lui que tu vois
hippolyte bougea les vitesses
différentes tellement il est allemand
[Musique]
ils vont
regarder
et ils contrôlent tellement son corps il
est capable passeur dès demain finir dès
demain en changer direction il bosse
bien défensivement moi je trouve mieux
que ce que vous décrivez un j'aime
j'aime bien comment ils orientent le le
porteur de balle comment ils peuvent
n'être vertical sans faire faute
je sais pas s'il va être numéro un chez
moi mais parce que vous pas force les
gens ils savent que j'aime beaucoup les
les porteurs de balle donc par rapport à
moins de banias maquis est une icône de
ouf et qui est pas un créateur ballaman
et donc gp que l'ue devait quitter
justement pour blessure proviennent pas
de la masse est vrai que mon physique
m'envoyer mac est un petit peu certaines
personnes il a tout ce que j'aime chez
un chien prospecter n'diaye et en plus
il a l'air de comprendre vraiment le
basket donc
il peut être il peut être numéro un chez
moi non prochain après j'ai pas encore
vu les autres joueurs à part une manière
fausse couche voilà je fais pas autant
dans ce cas la
nuit mais
ils montrent elles étaient là milliards
derrière lui dès qu'il bouge et la
lumière qui reprend vous
le savez c'est la lumière au bout du
chemin
lumière divine le les orioles
mais oui je comprends le tc que vaille à
marquer l'histoire scout c'est le
professionnel pour une lorsque tu es
avec un chrono plus jeune de tous les
temps c'est un projet très bien salaire
un gogo cftc soit ça se repère times et
l'iht 1 il voulait vraiment passé passé
pro et est rapidement et c'est le
prochain joueur qui a passé deux ans au
jilin aussi dit que la règle est encore
l'âme celle de l'âge ce ne sera pas le
dernier je pense je pense qu'on va voir
aussi peut-être doute énorme prospects
peut-être faire la même chose et puis
voix il est hors norme quoi car ils
sachent qui je suis très très risqué 10
la capacité à rentrer à 17 ans qu'on
aime qu'on 25 26 ans et c'est le
meilleur sur le terrain est le meilleur
joueur sur le terrain et tu te dis mais
attends là c'est une fin de match contre
eux riad jonathan kumming iam osé se
mesurer que j'ai donnée redit aussi des
mecs qui dans les idées des warriors qui
sont des vrais joueurs de basket des
scouts seigneur comme ça on ne comprend
pas comment c'est anormal c'est pas
normal
sa compréhension même d'hommes sa
compréhension du même temps lorsqu'ils
en un au paintball
les défenseurs sont de dos aux paliers
et malté qui manipule la défense comme
enjeu
puisque on a fait le tour sur ce côté
personne puisqu'on a fini d'entendre
bien
s'arrêter sinon moi ga par la capote la
joue
mais tu vois si il était dans la draft
2023 il est numéro il et 2022 et les
gagnants
donc c'est aussi voilà mais l'an dernier
aussi adroit ya il faut se poser la
question d'un vrai débat
voilà c'est prenant dès le niveau de
protection
alan je vais te libérer je sens tu
l'hypoglycémie pointe le bout de son nez
c'est gentil donc on va tirer merci
beaucoup d'être venu comme d'habitude
c'était super c à vous voilà merci à la
mousson et cette fois on parle bien de
saint-rosaire
intimâtes hiver des spoilers ouais mais
des gens semblent être la transition c64
de départ magnifique merci à l'âne
donc voilà j'ai demandé à tous ceux qui
étaient là ce soir de nous présenter
chacun joueurs de jean guy qui
utilisaient les biens donc on va faire
le décompte et puis donc vu que étalant
ses titres au vas-y sam houser d'où
vient-il pied est il que fait-il c'est
incroyable robo't vous avez n'arrête
sport
gt gt obliger un peu de faire le hummer
donc ça mother qui est un ailier de 24
ans 2 m 01 100 kg café trois premières
saisons à la fac à marquette avant de
transfert pour virginia
où il a fait d'ailleurs il a fait cinq
ans à la fin que j'ai fait une année red
shirt quand il ya transfert mais il a
joué quatre saisons on qui joue pour les
mêmes celtics donc les équipes de geely
est affiliée à boston non brevetés et a
signé un tour et contractants suite être
les boston celtics cet été
il me dit je crois bien si j'ai bien
retenu d'abord si à miami avant de se
rétracter pour signer un beau style ici
ce qu'il a fait mais moi y'a l'honneur
comme
pour info il a un petit frère qui joue
aussi à la famille shalit
merci c'est ça
c'est un joueur très vif c'est un joueur
qui est passé la saison dernière à la
fac il est passé à 0 2 4% ce prêt aux
lancers francs de faire une saison en 50
40 90
quel type de joueur sait c'est un
spécial du foot c'est un choix
essentiellement au volant catch and
shoot et retenez bien ça parce que c'est
le seul truc qui sait faire
mais voir un peu ce que ça me fait drôle
parce qu'être mais par contre il le fait
il le fait de façon remarquable que je
laissais quatre saisons à la fac ces
quatre saisons à plus de 40 % aux tirs
je suis pas seul on se rend compte du
truc dont un pic à quasiment 49% et à
chaque fois c'est pas sur une ou deux
tentatives c'est sur sainte six
tentatives voire plus
donc si vous faites de calcul sur quatre
ans il ya trente matches un peu pas une
trentaine de matchs par saison
6 tirs par match voilà sur quatre ans
donc ça vous fait quand même un bon
échantillon
pareil au niveau des lancers francs là
quatre saisons à plus de 80% on a même
deux saisons à 90 ans au plus donc voila
cela confirme le fait que ce soit un
excellent shooteur après comme j'ai dit
en dehors du cloud c'est très limité
voire juste mauvais c'est un passeur
fonctionnel c'est pas quelqu'un qui va
gêner la circulation du ballon mais il
faut rien faire d'autre en attaque et en
défense y sera clairement négatif il
faudra le cacher et c'est dû notamment à
des qualités athlétiques sont très
limitées et en fait il a un trou il ya
ce profil un peu bâtard en fait de poste
3-4 qui est trop lent pour défendre les
postes 3 et qui est passée physique et
puissants pour défendre les postes 4
donc donc voilà c'est vrai que c'est ce
que tu achètes avec lui c'est le shoot
et d'ailleurs pourquoi moi j'y croirai
n'diaye est pourquoi il faut garder un
oeil dessus c'est justement sur ce shoot
passe par un bien on sait qu'au delà des
stars les autres joueurs
qui doivent rentrer dans des rôles en
fait d'où le nom de role players
d'ailleurs et dans la nba actuelle
chaque équipe a besoin d'un joueur qui
prend ce rôle de spécialiste du shoot et
sa mother peut clairement être
en fait quand je vois des max truths ou
d un ken robinson au heat garrison
matthews quête simpson
davis bertan pour lui s'il est un peu
fâché avec son shoot de quelques d'angle
voilà mais je me dis ces gars là qui ont
un peu le même profil causeur c'est à
dire des qualités athlétiques limitée
une défense douteuses mais un shoot
élite ils ont réussi à trouver une place
en nba et je me dis y'a pas de raison
que vos or ne trouve pas sa place mais
voilà ailleurs la volonté des autres et
quand même moi j'aime bien sûr son qi
basket c'est quand même un garçon qui
récrit basket qui web à cesser ce que
les contredire passeur fonctionnel c'est
que c'est pas un gars qui se dit je suis
bon que aux shoots dont je vais faire
que ajouté il va pouvoir reconnaître à
quel moment il faut shooter à quel
moment il doit lâcher
et pour le côté défensif parce que même
si c'est pas un bon défenseur turc il
est rarement très très mal traités en
fait mais sache alors oui ça me fera
jamais un bon défenseur mais ça permet
de limiter un peu la casse comprimé
cause
mérite aussi moi j'y crois dans une
place enviée et je pense qu'il aura en
théorie n'aurait même pas besoin de
faire ses valises pour aller très loin
parce qu'il ya une équipe dans le
massachusetts il dirait pas non à un
shooter un spécialiste du foot dans son
effectif je pense
wes à mesure on l'avait un peu un peu ce
que j'ai pas sourire et beaucoup parlé
l'année dernière mieux
on n'avait pas beaucoup parlé mais on
l'avait tous trois cadres en fait dans
le truc c'est que la fin red shirt et
virgin ajoute très lentement et donc
toujours difficile il y avait plus que
shooter avec un imprononçable un italien
qui était plus robuste ring extérieur
utile à pieds les mains il avait un
autre coéquipier aussi qu a fini en 50
90 et qu'elles étaient 40 98 mbj
à huîtres et moules effectivement mais
très haut très murphy au premier tour
19e
vexé renom avec avec les na'vi sk jones
ça doit être ça tu dois t'en aperçois de
cet epic en plus non
oui oui et il voyait vraiment une équipe
de la chute est justement celle qui
tenait le ballon qui a coûté qui a
transféré du coup
moi ça me faisant le point que je sais
que je préfère son petit frère et donc
c'est toujours compliqué quand un frère
qui ressemble plus à un dylan aussi
coach qui donc j'avais plus le frérot de
jouer en ligne de mire
belle sur sam hamad de bienvenue à
moi j'ai jamais été incroyablement fans
si on compare à des joies comme duncan
robinson bonne qu'elle ramène ce qui est
intéressant avec lui c'est qu'on peut
l'utiliser dans n'importe quelle
situation en sortie d'écran du neuf
sam houser je peux plus de difficultés à
bram ailier des dix joueurs qui ont fait
leurs cg je donne toujours l'exemple
canonique de vieil homme mike miller
avec miami en 2002 2011 2014 où est-ce
qu'ils défendaient
connectique qui faisait le mettait les
trois points il était ce qu'on appelle
un qi en dessous d'eux ils arrivaient
tout toujours dernier en attaque qui
peut être trois points
pourquoi pas pourquoi parce que ça rend
jusqu'à pas capable de jouer de jouer un
rôle comme seule limite est liée à
chaque match
jamais été justement précaution dit par
spécialisation n'est jamais d
extrêmement convaincu mais pourquoi
pourquoi je pense je pense que ce jour
ajustements qui joue à l'intérieur de
ses moyens c'est très important pour moi
dans mon évaluation puis qui connaît son
rôle comme les y force et dans la vie il
faut se placer faut faut jouer avec ses
forces avec ses faiblesses si s'épaissit
et qui devient pesant d'écran cause du
pic est peut-être que ça peut être
atteint sans lui sera de soleil ma femme
beaucoup plus à un cap qu'un brouhaha
seconde est ce qu'il aura pas la
rotation des hanches pour courir dans
les écrans et pouvoir se tourner tirer
c'est vraiment plus un mec qui va ce qui
va faire écran
afin de chasser plus un tulle utilisera
plus en dessous le corner que
hors écran parce que oui comme tu dis là
pas c'est pas aussi fluide qu'un duncan
robinson ou juste qu'on peut faire je
pense que c'est un tout et sait que sa
part moi vite en fait c'est plus le
shoot est magnifique mais c'est normal
mais même au niveau du déplacement jeudi
à wave niveau des déplacements le temps
de prendre position au niveau des pieds
de bouger les hanches et où c'est quand
même beaucoup plus lent que
c'est pas le même physique
lui la puce la plus physique de 3,4 que
de que d'autres choses en fait c'est
après cet échange
m 100 kg je peux pas parler
et 80 kg en vrai il y avait une très
belle perle malheureusement qu'on voit
plus beaucoup
sur les premiers matchs que j'ai
commandé cette saison trèbes le père luc
hornet sam houser et franchement c'était
plaisant à regarder oui on en 2022 et
j'ai le droit de dire une très belle
paire luc hornets en 11 heures et cinq
sets 6-7 très sceptique ce qu'ils
connaissent déjà les gens des knicks les
gens
sont devenus joueurs qui passent par les
knicks qui sont montpellier sur une des
jeunes de sonder les eaux des liquides
c'est plus compliqué que les gens devant
donné que saint-jean next jeu
mais aurait du coup elle est vraiment
une belle paire avec une cornette sainte
quitterie très sévère mais ça a hésité
pas à les dessous est allé prendre prend
des positions donc c'est pour ça moi
j'aime et ce surtout ce côté un peu old
qu'il a un en attaque qui porte aussi
bien te planter train de poing sur la
gueule meilleur match je crois c'est le
deuxième ou troisième match de pré
saison que j'avais commenté ou une
simple que j'avais demandé si toi aussi
tu voulais dire comme un thème était pas
dit pour ce disque au soir là
où il plante
33.3 autres aux 35 points à y prendre
six ou sept tirs à trois points est le
message qu il en met 5 voire 6 c quand
il prend feu sans odeur faut pour
frapper les pompiers la maréchaussée
pour frapper tout le monde parce qu'il
ya un syndicat et en plus avec les
shooteurs qu'il ya autour parce qu'il
n'est pas le seul
c'est compliqué à arrêter quand les
celtics y sont annoncés mais bon après
ça c'est la sphère de séparer la sphère
de tout le monde pierre du thé la parole
je vais te lancer sur toi ton chouchou
toi tu m'as parlé de craie grande halle
2 c'est pas un joueur qui est très très
jeune j'ai vu les 25 ans un mineur
gauche et c'est ça effectivement la
lohner z ailleurs meilleur gaucher
longueuil en est
il a fait ces quatre à l'université il
est passé à côté de mémoire il a fait
même fils et j'ai transféré lors de la
saison 2010 et 2018 à memphis tennessee
pardon télé simard titre exactement
chris martin n'était pas tennessee
c'était pas c'était pas le glas de tous
cas c'est aussi
il a fait aussi
game ge geely il avait eu une fille ce
week-end et après il a fait la dernière
fois qu'il a dit
tennessee marquer mais si c'est martine
way du coup une première saison de
jining pour lui un sortie d'université
vieux pour les standards de la g-league
mais en fait ça ennuie
les nets actuellement la halle des nets
ils sont bons c'est le début de saison
et comme j'ai dit c'est assez inégaux au
niveau des autres jouets mais un assez
gros indicateurs il ya eu neuf matches
joués par les nets il n'a pas joué trois
ils ont perdu les trois de 30 pays
je pensais que c'est un assez bon
indicateur pour
montrer à quel point il est important il
est à
il est à 25 points
25 points en 27 points 27 points 5
rebonds 5 passes de moyenne avec une
interception
pourtant quand on le voit comme ça il
est pas voilà quand il m 93 83 kg il
fait un peu frais luc et tu vois ce
n'est pas la description physique elle
est pas alléchante quoi mais quand on
regarde quand on regarde vraiment les
matches c'est impressionnant à quel
point il dépeint il déteint sur toute
l'équipe s'est il a fait trois pointes
et june joueur de la semaine sur la
deuxième semaine sur deux semaines 2 de
régulière
ils achètent trois matches à 40 points
dont une pointe à car 9 9
mais c'est toi en fait moi ce qui m'a
intéressée est de savoir pour les gens
qui nous écoutent et qui connaissent pas
non plus c'est de savoir quel est son
quelles sont les qualités qui pourraient
lui permettre justement d'accéder à
l'échelon supérieur
son shoot il a un très beau shoot
notamment à trois points
en six thèmes 1 sortie d'écran
surtout en sortie d'écran prendre
beaucoup beaucoup trois points sortie
d'écran
il aime pas il est pas trop catch and
shoot même si ça peut rentrer mais il
est vraiment surtout en sortie de
dribble en sortie d'écran et
après la défense la défense c'est
vraiment l'un de ses points forts après
ce qui pourrait vraiment s'imposer
s'imposer en ligue raté un spot de
rotation avec des vrais minute i still
10 15 minutes pourquoi pas
ça semble compliqué mais gratter des
petites minutes par-ci par-là coût de 7
8 minutes avec les nets si jamais il ya
des mais si j'en suis convaincu que yi
pour le faire parce que c'est un team
player pour une grosse équipe ça
pourrait être un très bon team player un
peu à la
moindre mesure mais on peut à lalinde
riches à mettre clippers va dire un peu
la lande riches à mettre aux clippers ou
à la
latière ici quand il avait des vraies
minutes donc il ya vraiment deux un truc
à faire avec craig en donne ici non mais
bon j'ai eu envie d'en parler parce que
j'ai mûri qui jouent en jean njeunga
j'ai oublié que il existait aussi mais
si vous voulez je peux vous en faire une
double offert la double la double
joueurs
on va dire faire passer tout le monde
parce qu'on est déjà quand même assez en
retard
j'ai pas eu le rhin
si on veut finir pas de 10h à 12h
continue à avancer
d'ailleurs on va passer au choix de ben
là aussi un choix de rumeurs
absolument un choix énorme parce qu'il
doit jouer deux matchs j league et les
conforts pour la ligue
oui il est vrai
un des chouchous de l'histoire si matt
mcbride j'ai regardé les deux matches il
a absolument tout défoncer j'ai 3 39
points 7 passes décisives le premier le
deuxième 16 points 16 points 16 passes
décisives il était partout il est
magnifique il défend sur 94 pied il
défend la longueur de terrain il est
important la page et en plus si fait six
pieds un pouce donc c'est pas un mec 85
mais il est très très très très bas il
est 10 heures beaucoup de son centre de
gravité très bas pour passer
les sous ses couvertures l'état n'y
change les très bons pour naviguer dans
les petits espaces sans tuer son dribble
il est très passif est un peu
hilton plus chier fou en sortie de
dribble trouve que des fois il dribble
le poids absolument poirier mais je
trouve aussi que je trouve aussi que des
fois quand les compagnies c'est un peu
difficile mais est ce qu'il ya une année
à gagner absolument se joue en nba mal
aux mecs là et l'on pourrait même dire
qu'avec les blessures sont toniques ce
que c'est probablement le meilleur
meneur des knicks sont présentement
étudiées sur leurs auteurs moi j'aime
beaucoup un badge mcbride donnez-moi
james mcbride patron des vics à la place
d'alex bucks n'est pourtant qu'un
mage blanc rappelle ainsi t il a été
drafté l'année dernière donc on début de
second tour il faut agir
alors c'est une petite petite grotte une
petite carotte qui n'a pas la personne
qui défend plus grand que ce qui peut
faire par rapport à sa taille je trouve
parce qu'il a une envergure de foule il
a d'ailleurs je crois me tarde cependant
à faire quelques choses en main et une
envie aussi quand il défend un côté un
peu
battus c'est bien fou par rapport aux
dribbles dans le côté un peu brouillon
mais je trouve quand il défend il ya un
côté un peu de pitbull present in your
way très pressant sur l'homme
physiquement
oui moi j'arrête au jour le jour à plat
et parce que si si j'en parle moins on
est là encore vendeuse en
transition en biais sur le fait qu' il
s'appelle juiceman bouhati son surnom et
tous m'ont appelé comme ça il ya une
raison c'est parce qu'il prenait que des
poulpes à mi-distance aussi et en hindi
on lui demanderait de faire soit du près
du panier ceux du tir à trois points et
moi j'avais d'action sur l'adaptation
qui pouvait avoir et fallait qu'ils
jouent peut-être plus au football et
voilà après si tu le situe le pensait
que du kif l'espagne près de flore
garder jouer il est trop bien et il faut
qu'il développe un tir à trois points de
solutions
c'est vrai que c'est à moi si la moitié
at il attiré bien mieux que ce que je
pensais au début la fédé très très beau
démarrage eux aux tirs extérieurs
libre à toi tu n'es pas encore exprimé
j'ai longuement hésité je ne sais j'ai
dû de l'année puis lapointe en fait il
ya eu un nom kick du direct et comme
tout le monde l'a pris on a dû changer
puis finalement personne ne le prenais
donc on voit comment parler faut lui
rendre hommage
je te laisse le disais ah ben oui il est
là qui sonne fort keane
[Musique]
qu'il est important
c'est ça un joueur déjà qu'est-ce qui
fait angie
12h02 offense à la dignité il est
beaucoup trop là-bas il est drafté on
rappelle au second tour je crois qu'ils
chutent énormément kim johnsson la
plupart d'entre eux comme ils prennent
bientôt premier tour fin de premier tour
du coup non c'est barcelone qui
voit les budgets pas seulement
8 mai
premier tour avec benoît 54 et il chute
énormément la plupart d'entre nous peut
être que je déconne répète pour toi mais
on l'avait loterie moi je l'avais 8 je
crois chez moi c'est un jeu là reda
c'est ce jour là où brett hull avait
très très haut ces romans que chez nous
qu'il est un homme - c'est romain qui
avait du mal avec les petits moyens nous
ne rien y voyant meneur de jeu roman et
faut rappeler que hugh johnson que la
vingtaine et c'est nous qui fait un
parcours freshman athenes 6 et pastor
frosch de l'équipe avec jon spring quand
il arrive là bas son coach et lui dit
qu'est ce que tu veux être il lui répond
je vais être le poste 4 défensifs et
reborn ce que dit b tu vas être
l'arrière au score star il dit ouais
mais moi que tu veux que le poste 4
défensifs de l'équipe et de là je suis
tombé amoureux de ce joueur qui était un
slasher de ouf qui avait un premier pas
plus plus plus capable de partir au
moins des contrats avec des deux mains
capable d'accélérer dans son drive ce
qui est très rare et qu'on aime beaucoup
c'est un athlète fou détente sèche
incroyable défenseur pitbull et
il a été drafté par les clippers et
c'est ce que je crois que j'aime le
moins qui peut arriver à prospecter
drafté par une équipe qui a eu lieu en
un roster complet ils font une bille et
touquet ils se disent non on a un choix
de draft on sait pas quoi en faire venez
on prend jeunes à potentiel dépit comme
ça au pire tant pis y est au mieux on
peu délité vous louper sur le côté sans
le faire jouer quand on aura une
superstar sauf que là dit c'est pas tout
y est et qu'il faudra joue et
j'avais très peur parce que je parle
avec des potes des clippers powell nous
devons faire un soutien des élites et
kim johnsson ses pinces rien dit on voit
cette année au coût du côté de agua
caliente j'espère que je le dis pas trop
mal il est à
23% à 3 points pour trois tentatives par
match qui est affreux 67% lancers francs
mais il tourne à 16 points de moyenne il
est à 5 rebonds 3 5 passes un style 1,5
bloc c'est un joueur complet hyper cinq
ballons par match ce qui est formidable
la mauvaise foi bah oui non mais c'est
c'est clair qui perd beaucoup de ballons
mais c'est un potentiel brut il faut le
faire se lâcher il faut le faire
attaquer du panier il faut le faire
jouer ce guerrier il est trop fort pour
pour dj ligue et je pense que l'équipe
est en train de ruiner son potentiel en
fait et ça me fout les boules ça me fout
vraiment les boules donc milité pour qui
une fois keane johnson pour qu'il rende
autant d'une équipe et de billets et et
qu'ils puissent se développer
vers moi ça m'avait amusés entre
guillemets le fait que derrière nous et
le premier joueur qui a fait rentrer
finalement c'est plus visible au stade
parce qu'ils ont besoin de points en
fait les points soit ils disent voilà
ils ont fait les clippers ont décimé la
personne qui peut mettre en pagne et
donc il avait plu a besoin de deux euros
de pitbull défensive des raiders de
scoring et donc son prix beach à boston
mais bon il faut jouer à mirko fille 42
minutes par match donc je vais dix
minutes kim johnsson quoi ça ne dise
respectant dernière koffi mechac dans le
chat ou comme ça la plupart des gens ne
connaissent pas à venir confier la
raison
la limitation
et qu'il approuverait johnson il avait
déjà produit blanc je trouve qu'il est
sous côté là dessus il avait pris après
je laisserais des gens d'être moi - un
mouvement en parler mais c'était
vraiment un vrai dribbleur sauf que
quand tu joues à tennessee t'as pas trop
des espaces n'a pas de robin mais un mec
qui peut partir dès demain changé de
mains en rêve
accéléré décéléré changer son allonge de
dribbles changé de mains en l'air finir
des paiements il ya peu de mecs nba qui
arrive tout cas là peu de prospects du
top 10 qui peuvent le faire donc moi
c'est pas là dessus qu'il veut
développer son tir à trois points
son tir tout court en général mais c'est
au début si vous pouvez aussi tennessee
dernière et c'est vrai que début c'était
très compliqué et dans la sélection et
dans
dans la réussite après avoir lu sur deux
années on a vu une vraie progression
notamment avec
la capacité à se créer un petit âne
jumper kanak m mais après à trois points
c'était encore compliqué puis après
beauté n'est si c'est encore une fois
c'est un jeu assez particulier c'est à
l'ancienne très très très très
structurant n'attaque
pas trop la tête toujours combien cris
oui forcément c'est toujours compliqué
j'ai l'impression pour les voir j'ai
toujours cette impression là avec elle
mais bon qui en johnson était au dessus
le titre ou pas
ouais ça va enfin ne jeter pas le foot
et du coup en gros le voyait en lui ce
qu'on voit actuellement c'est juste un
pile volet défensif et du coup j'ai
forcément automatiquement il avait pc
ans que je l'avais vu pensant je sais
pas où vous l'aviez moi je l'avais enfin
de loterie de la limite
de mémoire je l'avais entre douze et
quinze autres comme ça
ouais j'ai acheté pas le shoot et et du
cou à force est de constater pour
l'instant j'ai raison après je ne lui
souhaite que de réussir à se trouver un
shoot mais vu les qualités défensives je
pense que tu as toujours besoin d'un
pull défensif concert dans une équipe
après enseigne dans la nba actuelle si
tu mets pas de point c'est compliqué
d'exister sur le long terme et je pense
que ça lui fait défaut actuellement mais
je pense pas en fait que tu le donnes tu
le cros pour du tir georges pour moi
c'est un slasher ça mais qui prend le
ballon qui fera des petits carreaux qui
attaque le cercle genre c 1,5 c un petit
mieux classés 1
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir dans le style
là tu as dwyane wade par au point d'en
parler moi je voyais pas mal de mons
mousse mes deux tournois est un
agresseur de poignet qui condamne une
faute dans ce cas là on en revient à ce
qu'ils utilisent et à leur est en fait
le problème c'est ça on sait qu'un bon
de le rappeler que la projection d'un
joueur enfin le développement d'un
joueur aussi fort soit-il le beau temps
que potentiel qui peut avoir dépend
énormément de beaucoup de choses qu'ils
maîtrisent pas comme l'environnement
d'un sacre il dans laquelle et ont plein
de choses comme ça qui ne maîtrisent pas
et un joueur peut être plus talentueux
aucun autre mais se retrouver à avoir
une bonne carrière voire même sombré à
coups de mauvaises environnement ou une
mauvaise franchise dans laquelle il est
tombé au mauvais moment sa carrière
c'est un mec qui tantôt se tape paul joe
g convoyer les nantis est vrai que tu as
moins d'espacé que quand efron
stagnerait thaïlande où il est invaincu
qui même si j'aime beaucoup ce mot qui
l'emmenait
la question très bonne du vin c'est
l'ancienne star de doug s'inquiète qui a
jamais réussi à s'imposer en nba qui est
toujours resté un projet 5 étoiles et
qui ne jouera jamais loin de pied voilà
c c'est un fantasme très bonne du
valhalla ne on parle comme un fantasme
aussi qui restera un fantasme et qui
finira par partir en chine
et qui jouent également là où bêtement
d'année alors ça faut plus demandé à
notre spécialiste j'ai dit que je sais
qu'il y fait des piges tous les autres
et qui change des types de clés dans
tous les enfants inscrits mais moi j'ai
pas du tout écouté je tenterai direct en
vo autre chose je suis désolé c'est pas
très loin du ballon se demandait ce
qu'il
put est un très beau duel
avec le chili
c'est les soldes
c'est les deux gars de sa part d'ong ou
là je suis je pas moins
très bonne duval fra wilma ça c'est le
genre de joueurs on les voit tous les
ans on se dit merde au
pdc ur de
6 à yatama ce moment yeux
grand rapids gold qui le guette ses
23 points hier soir
23 points hier soir 23 points 4 rebonds
7 passes cette phase 2 sur 6 à trois
points 7 sur 13 aux tirs c'est pas mal
c'est le genre de joueur qu'on voit tous
les hadjis et on se dit donc quand
est-ce qu'ils vont repasser téléch non
mais il ne passe jamais
c'est compliqué 31% à 3
4 par match
c'est
j'étais jeune je croyais à padova froid
toujours
avant qu'ils jouent à duke ouais mais
là ce que je vous ai proposé à tous ceux
qui sont lassés de on va finir les
restes dix grosses minutes on va finir
son flq donc on va prendre toutes vos
questions donc n'hésitez pas à poser des
questions sur son agrès ce soit sur la
g-league vu qu'on a quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît en jean et j'étais peintre
question va essayer de reprendre un
maximum là j'ai vu une question c'est
une question points depuis là c'est
dommage je vous la met en dehors de
scout est ce qu'il ya de prospection
déjà annoncé qu'ils rejoignent nine
nights pour les prochaines j'ai vu en
plus interview il ya pas longtemps mais
j'ai pas enregistré moi je suis très
grave pendant cinq mois les prospects
2023/2024 peux pas encore en parler ben
peut-être que tu te dis nous prenons
je fais la recherche présentement des
musulmans aussi à une question que je me
pique sûrement donc sais pas s'il va y
aller mais en 5 min p de se rejoindre
l'an prochain la tunique qui fasse pas
de deux en lice c'est très probable en
tout cas la plupart des observateurs
pensent qu'il va partir ensuite en
professionnel sûrement aux libanais que
moi j'ai vu que je regarde pas tout si
scouting etc je sais pas du tout qui va
arriver tant que c'est pas dans les chu
yo et que j'entends parler ou du moins
c'est officiel mais ouais du coup un
vrai ce que je peux espérer c'est que au
moins qu'on est comme un peu l'an
dernier des prospects de très haut
niveau comme com
comme celle une green et qu on puisse
passer une bonne année de la ladies
night l'an prochain et qu'on se retrouve
un prochaine la victoire acquise dans la
merde on a évolué boys mais on avait
motivé ses scouts emerson et ça fait mal
quoi d'ailleurs j'ai envie de comparer
l'année dernière par la j league et qui
fait un super début de saison là sur les
premiers matches et des chaînes x le
meneur qui jouent ces housses c'est le
club affilié à houston soit célébrée au
g des vols avaient peur santa fe voilà
c'est ça le long métrage aux jeux
s'assurant par étudie ajouté vapeur 110
et
il va en avez vous rappelle qu'on la
laisse écouter ce se voir là pas mal la
dernière il ya un gros problème ce fait
il est incapable de rentrer attire 4 m
il y avait un corps qui était assez
présent et puis une vraie capacité pour
le foie a donné l' utilité pas mal donc
ça celui par exemple peut-être que il
peut profiter de sa forme après essayer
d'arracher à spot dans deux uniques il a
pris deux ou trois pauses entre la
saison dernière et cette saison et il
s'est trouvé une espèce de cammas tweed
de grands malades avec dry ça fait trop
quatre matchs d'affilée que les mecs qui
sont à 20 points chacun ils sont à 20
points 10 passes chacun et le duo est
incroyable à voir jouer je vous
conseille d'aller voir les images de les
derniers matches des reapers c'est super
agréable à voir jouer comme ça ils sont
tous les descentes sur le terrain ça
combine la remontée de balle est
beaucoup plus fluide même après dans le
jeu dans la distribution c'est beaucoup
plus fluide et j'espère vraiment que don
avant de dire oui quand même mais
j'espère vraiment que moyen des deux
trois spots au sporting et parce que des
chaînes x ne méritent ils vraiment le
physique et les qualités athlétiques
pour pour y aller et il faut juste que
lui faire bosser son shoot mais le coach
des vipers mahmoud abdoul fatah qui est
en plus d'être un être humain très très
sympathique et très accessible et un
super coach est une superstar au niveau
du
du ch du shooting de l'open pardon donc
ouais moi j'y crois et j'espère que
déchets disent pas pour avoir ce spot
dans la rotation des roquettes ou d'azur
franchise
à j'aime bien cette question même si
elle n'est pas trop sur l'algérie j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya de moins en moins
de français vigiles ou draft un one big
un ovni est ce qu inquiétant génération
va rêver moi je suis moyennement des
craintes ou constat en bref moi aussi
parce que déjà rien que break sur ses
dunks engrais là en terme de joueurs
éligibles il ya du alors qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont y aller ou pas ça c'est
autre chose mais en terme de joueurs
éligibles 11 ça diabaté ousmane dieng
hugo besson ismaël kamagaté
joe hachem balade de 15 heures en solo
qu'elle rompt de légna
donc ça fait déjà
10 gains aussi une tonique me ouais
aussi donc ça fait déjà six sept joueurs
donc c'est c'est déjà pas mal alors
choix ils vont pas tous y aller et cie
vont ils seront pas tous de rareté mais
ça fait ça fait déjà 6 7 jours je vous
sais ça pas mal derrière talent et à
mettre hors et à l'airé risacher
wen est arrivé au camp des non car est
bon
quand il s'appelle 6-10 6 au cou wesh
celui qui est ici ou là
j'ai perdu son
qui était en
tête à la coupe du monde fis balle
bien tu disais qu'il avait pas demain
pas le pivot la tumeur
il est vrai nom j'ai plus un
réajustement ainsi
si oui la grande cagnotte on voit tout
et
voilà le but mais
il a d'abord à l'arizona
imada kivu et du coup jacques laroche
au texas tech aussi
aller voir les matchs est pour rien il
ya des trucs sympas à regarder
lanta c'est pour pour pierre quand il
est là et ce qui est des équipes de
geely qui sont plus reconnus pour leur
fabrication que d'autres alors moi
instinctivement j'ai envie de parler du
heat qui sort à chaque fois des mecs des
débats et joueurs mais est-ce que c'est
la g-league ou est-ce que c'est
spoelstra
il n'y a pas vraiment de grosses grosses
formations en fait c'est ça je pense que
là
qu'on dira le d'erreurs que soit enfin
les gens c'est qu'en fait il faut pas
prendre de la geely comme un centre de
formation c'est que tu ailles parle de
formation c'est un peu là c'est un peu
révélateur de de ce dont je me bats de
ce contre je me bats kosyam ce qu'on
fait a dit que c'était pas un centre de
formation c'est une ligue de
développement mais pas seulement en fait
c'est un peu mon agenda que j'essaie de
de combattre c'est que c'est pâques
unique de développement et surtout les
mecs ont des ondes et des vraies
qualités
et après niveau formation les mecs en
pétition juste polis angeli c'est
vraiment delà de l'amélioration déjà sur
déjà des très bonnes bases donc sur ce
qui est sorti on a vu des warriors smile
aguiche jordan foule
kunda reese witherspoon qui est l'homme
qui est le mec que je voulais dont je
voulais parler qui a fait quelques
matches
qu'on minga qui sordide night
sinon il ya les roquettes aussi qu'il ya
eu une flopée incroyable de jours avec
le co vide harmonie groupe dit des
chaînes x
y en a tellement que j'arrive pas à les
citer
que
les chaînes x harmonie brooks harmonie
brooks d'ailleurs qui j'espère va faire
est vrai coaching sa carrière une scène
qui là encore est liée avec les
roquettes j'espère vraiment qu'il va
continuer parce que c'est un joueur de
malade mental on se rend pas compte que
ce mec si je vais minutes par match il
peut planter au moins 15 points par
match on est tranquille
les roquettes ça a été une grosse écurie
parce qu'ils font beaucoup combien ça au
coach abdel fattah comme j'en parlais
tout à l'heure ils font beaucoup combien
ces il n'hésite pas dès qu'ils a besoin
avec angie livre parce qu'ils savent que
que c'est la meilleure moyenne de
recruter gel pour pas cher et
ils savent comment ils ont montré qu'ils
n'ont pas de temps d'adaptation et qui
se passe je dirais donc vraiment c'est
sinon toronto aussi les a sortis fred
weill et fred 22 crise boucher
pascal siakam
que des monstres donc ouais comme ça je
dirais toronto houston et économique
alors après moi je crois qu'il ya aussi
un truc à moi chaque fois que j'entends
ça moi j'ai l'impression ses gammes
aussi après ça dépend des volontés des
franchises de s'investir dans sa ou pas
des raisons toutes les franchises ne
sont pas forcément dans l'objectif de
former des joueurs qui vont récupérer
après
systématiquement fort bien sûr comment
les différentes franchises parce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi et comment
les différentes franchises mettent leur
tout est par exemple pour moi c'est
significatif s'ils prennent des gens on
sait très bien que hausse et puis pour
faire de nombreuses choses ou plus un
profil mais pas vraiment pour potentiel
voit
dans une brute et oui absolument et
arguments pour voir justement une pause
mais comme un inconfort avec l'idée
d'avoir cette règle qu'est ce qu'on
appelle en amérique sont les mineurs
mais ce qui est vraiment comme une
deuxième
division
de la libye pour
l'europe et y aurait moins d'inconfort
une incompréhension peut-être justement
à savoir comment se servir de ce qui est
des équipes qui qui n'a pas le sport à
long terme des équipes qui sont qui voit
le penser à long terme de développer un
système qui produit ses propres joueurs
des équipes qu'il faut ben on voit la
culture se développe vite et bien avec
cet exemple
justice jeunes y compris une dernière
question puis après on va s'arrêter là
ça fait déjà deux heures qu'on est là
selon vous est ce qu'il ya une filière
cursus de formation qui est plus
importante pour arriver au chili gubbio
nba
je comprends pas la question bah
je comprends la question sur lequel est
le meilleur moyen d'arriver en
bas juste et reprend sa puce est inquiet
comme
pour des périodes
très honoré les intérêts que je défende
mais ouais ça a plus été planifiée
jusqu'à présent parce que lynette c'est
un mode finalité dadjé les gamins ça a
été beaucoup de
nouveaux qui a encore après un départ
certain
donc beaucoup plus inquiet mais dans les
futures données je vois vraiment l'adieu
la geely comme véritable concurrent de
l'acier interne on l'avait déjà dit
d'ailleurs je crois la saison dernière
vous tous beaucoup de personnes emparés
le juge de paix de la dgid en fait ce
sera là la draft et notamment la
réussite ou non en nba dès des joueurs
de jerry qui auront été drafté et donc
la saison dernière c'était drinking a
par exemple quitte à en figure de proue
en fait je pense pas qu'on puisse tirer
des conclusions tout de suite sur la
réussite ou non de la g-league parce que
parce que le premier roi qui est drafté
c'est déjà une grille n'est qu'il est
encore dans sa première saison nba donc
je pense que vous vraiment voir un
échantillon assez grand pour évaluer la
réussite ou non de la g-league sur sa
capacité à être plus importants tous nos
créanciers il faudra attendre encore
trois ou quatre romans et de voir
plusieurs joueurs draftés comment il se
comporte sur plusieurs saisons bjelland
pourra vraiment se demander si est-ce
que la g-league est un meilleur parcours
que l'acier ou est ce que c'est juste
différent ou est ce que c'est
mango
huawei qui le but aussi de mettre
joueurs au collège séduit données de
l'adversité c'est lui donner un contexte
compétitif où il voit une opportunité de
montrer sa valeur est il beaucoup
justement de jeunes coureurs qui
refusent d'aller au collège choisissent
tout chemin soit par les délais qui
soient par la nouvelle zélande soit par
la chine on se rappellera emmanuel
roudier pacs que l'acier jusqu'à il ya
très longtemps de payer voire qui ce
sont des joueurs qui viennent souvent
d'une situation familiale où ils ont des
obligations financières envers enfin
déjà on se rappellera quelques légumes
par exemple une petite fille qui le
croient 3 en ligne à ligne en mangeant
19 ou métal donc tu peux pas rester
pendant quatre ans à l'université à ne
rien recevoir parce qu'il va nourrir ça
fait donc ce qui est intéressant avec la
g league sait que ça va être un contexte
compétitif qui porte encore plus
pertinent que la lessive parce que c'est
tout des joueurs qui ont bien joué dans
les séries comme disait alan plutôt est
ce qu'il y avait justement des jouets
qui sait comment la crème de la crème
qui ont des dents les joueurs top
joignant conférence et du show c'est
très jeune beaucoup ça c'est
révolutionnaire c'est à dire que on
prend les 60 meilleurs pour aller dans
la nba c'est 4000 joueurs les 60 route
après ils vont ils vont se greffer à la
g-league
athlétiquement parleurs je crois qu'ils
ont tous à gagner à les anges et les gi
à se développer professionnellement et
pour moi c'est vraiment la vie tant
qu'on a la chance de faire autant
d'argent que ces gens-là
froyo absolument télé c'est bien
l'éducation
métier par là quatre ans pour être
comptable qui font à 90 dollars par
année où tu vas faire genre l'équivalent
de toutes invitées à vay par un an joyel
bible surface que tu aimes en plus pour
moi c'est même pas une question
qui noter qu'il ya de plus en plus de
et puis en plus de choix aux trophées
maintenant entre la 6ème et la g-league
le portail n'en a pas encore parlé mais
ça se saurait tarder je pense aussi la
haine dit elle
les clubs allemands d'europe en europe
on a déjà beaucoup les jeunes je
me connecte
donc il ya de plus en plus aussi de
maintenant les feuilles et le côté aussi
à l'international qui fait qu' il ya de
plus en plus de choix pour les prospects
et c'est très bien repro d'ailleurs tu
vois pour nous c'est horrible
mais rien de ce qu'ils font les gars
arrêtez quoi parce que franchement quand
tu fais de la n6 et qu'après tout apte à
la ddcs de l'overtime du high school de
l'europe et où on pète les plombs quoi
et puis oui et c'est comme ça on n'a pas
dix mille balles à footnote les
abonnements etc donc on galère l'a
arrêté de créer des liens multiples
vêtements un gros melting-pot là avec
tous en même temps et puis très bien
et c'est ici et si possible à des
horaires
non mais franchement franchement
j'aimerais ça ne m'avait pas
probablement jamais mais j'aimerais que
y ait une espèce d'associations comme ça
over time l'a ouverte m haies et
l'éthique je crois que ça y est j'y suis
je ne sais pas encore enseignées sur ça
et le magic j'aimerais franchement qu'on
ait une espèce de
espèce de mélange parce que ça pouvoir
en fait d'un ça donne une plateforme de
dégâts tous les joueurs qui sont pas
encore pro qui peuvent du coup se
montrer au niveau des scouts aimiez
parce que d'empêcher les scouts regarde
beaucoup les la digue directement
mais il escompterait beaucoup de jeans
donc 2e ça leur prairie une plate forme
un peu plus un peu plus grande que des
stores y installer des postes twitter
et
surtout sa deux ça donnerait des
ça donnerait des
opportunités de dengue aussi aux joueurs
de jean parce que ça ferait du coup
l'inversé ça leur donnerait le autour de
jean une expression médiatique qu'ils
ont pas en fait sur les réseaux de la
jeep parce que là djelic c
les réseaux moi j'essaye d'être un peu
moins aseptisé que
que
le conte originel mais le conte original
être très très aseptisé
et
des fois y'a des mecs qui plein de 45
points et on n'en parle pas quoi
donc voilà c'est c'est tout je voulais
finir sur ça
messieurs on va finir tout court je
crois ça fait plus de deux heures qu'on
est là donc on a fait un petit peu le
tour des principaux prospects gillings
le temps pour moi de remercier nos
invités du soir titres rock et la pierre
merci d'être venus et la prochaine fois
que tu viens faudra mettre une caméra
c'est le dilemme oui la pose souci merci
à vous pour la rotation c'était cool et
puis de toute façon
on te retrouve bientôt sur twitch
j'imagine alive extraordinaire avec
nicolas lang c'était trop tous les
vendredis soir 21h on est là voilà
titouan on va te retrouver avec the
green room sur 7,6 france et puis bien
sûr la scouting quad du ccs la dernière
fois c'était elle et d'équité ni la
stricte loi contiendra donc la prochaine
fois c'est très cool en tout cas ça
marche bel
bat on va te retrouver bientôt de toute
façon parce que tu décris d'articles ses
voyages en
jet
qui je crois est un ce prospect
je vais être
sur la croix de cars des spurs jouent ce
qu'on va parler
un jour on ne pas le voir du tout à la
graphie il faut le biais développé avec
une bonne situation
je suis ta maison tu passeras beaux
jours a bu je passerai bonjour à deux
amis bien sûr
c'est passé par là
et hiboux et les médias belges aussi y
est il y aura fière etc c'est la famille
bon les gars merci encore merci à tous
ceux qui étaient là avec nous vous êtes
de tout nombreux donc ça fait plaisir et
puis merci pour votre question qui sont
toujours assez pertinente on a une
pensée pour tous les copains qui sont de
la team envergure forcément d'adata team
les historiques le boss alex
d'ailleurs si vous avez loupé une
réunion d'anciens il ya une semaine
assez à cette heure là sur la drave 2017
c'était assez cool sur les peler les
erreurs qui ont été commises donc si
vous l'avez loupé c'est sur la chaîne
youtube allez-y vous allez passer un bon
moment puis savoir à peu près deux
heures vous connaissez de foire allez
ciao bye j'aimerais tous cas un des bus